[Music]
I wanted it so bad and he did it and at
long last we are back with the I am
non-gm speech chess championship brought
to you by chess comm we are in the
semi-finals and here we have both
international master Lina cash and sky
and international master teddy Coleman
Alina teddy welcome back thanks Robert
Thank You high and run and my first
question has to be which of dunya's
impressions that he was doing before the
show is your favorite Alina we'll start
with you we should definitely Teddy ago
with I'll go with Gary it's a tried and
true classic and Don aduba works for us
a Teddy in the work Teddy is is slowly
being prepared but you know it's like
coffee after I have to roast it for a
while Teddy's got that San Francisco
kind of clean crisp you know just eating
some avocado toast
you know don't mess me don't mess with
me kind of so so that's not as easy to
to kind of hook all right well I guess
I've already distracted show enough Don
de you can ask the players the real
chess questions you're the GM here all
right well I guess a question for both
of you Teddy and Alina there's of course
quite a long break between the first set
of matches and today's semi-final what
are some of the things that you did
during that break to keep yourself
informed do you feel like that Break
made you more anxious to play or do you
feel refreshed and maybe more ready to
fight them before
well I think if I can start this maybe I
should go first so my daily routine was
just was almost the same like every day
and not much has changed but of course
nowadays every opportunity to play chess
is very exciting and I am happy to be
able to play again mm-hmm yeah that's it
during the break I loved watching the
Nations Cup I thought that was super fun
to watch every day so I don't know if
that's preparation or not but it
certainly was like excellent chess and
yeah I guess you know the this
tournament has given me like you know a
good reason to really study chess again
so it's been it's been fun well you two
give the kindest and like most sincere
answer is possible to roast you guys I
mean yeah gentlemanly you know I I don't
know what else to ask I mean I guess
aleena back to you really quickly you
know in the first two matches they were
very close matches like Teddy the same
but at least are with you
do you anticipate another close match
have you sort of prepared your nerves
for a tight match in this one well my
nerves I are always ready for for my
matches so I didn't have to do some
extra work in in this case Danny what
about you yeah definitely the first two
matches where we're really down to the
wire so I don't know hopefully that's
good training for this one well you know
we'll give you both a little rest so you
can get ready for the games we thank you
for your participation and for
entertaining not just the fans but us
and putting up with us really because I
know absolutely been a handful already
in the brief time that we spent together
today but best of skill to both you and
good luck have some good chess set
thanks guys thank you
[Music]
because there has been a bit of a
breather between the quarterfinals and
semifinals of this I am NOT GM speech
Chess Championship we must remind you of
how we got here who has been eliminated
and as you see on the right side of the
bracket we have Teddy Coleman Alina
Cashman skya all right Danya you know
we're reminding everybody of what's
happened to close match ups Teddy just
eating by Danny wrench and then levy
frozen a two point spread in each
matchup and the mattress with elena
krasovskaya she beat Kristoff so lucky
by two and then Eric frozen by five but
that was entirely determined by the
bullet portion they went into that tide
so in this matchup between Teddy and
Alina who you got well I mean Teddy has
been just incredible he's been so clutch
he's been performing in critical moments
of the match and so has Alina Elena's
just gotten better and better in the
last match we were amazed at how the
match kept progressing and Alina kept
getting sharper and sharper I'm going to
have to go with Alina just because she's
more practiced obviously she's higher
rated but at the same time I love teddy
I think he's performed exceptionally I'm
gonna say this is gonna come down to the
bullet section that's going to be my
guess okay we just remind everybody the
format it is in the longest time is
spent in the five plus one segment
that's five minutes with one second
increment then we get to the
three-minute muscle one second increment
and finally to that bullet one plus one
and well a single elimination we already
seen who's been eliminated and with
Alina
she is the high rate in the classical
chess but we've seen Teddy upset players
who are more active than he is who are
higher rated and so the ratings don't
tell the whole story but you know I
think you have to give a nod to Alina
cassius Chaya but that may favor Teddy
he's been the underdog every single
match and yet he's prevailed in the
first two so it will be interesting
fight in this matchup indeed and the
fact that he maybe hasn't played as much
tournament chess is Alina that might not
be a bad thing
cuz sometimes you take a break from
chess now you come back and you're
hungry for the game and you're fresh and
you've got nothing to lose so Elena's
classical rating significantly higher
that's about 150 point difference but we
see chess con blitz rating don't sleep
on Ceti definitely not and I just want
to get to daily question in the mix
before the games take off because it's a
fun one I know Danya you love basketball
Michael Jordan and so the last dance is
on everyone's mind but the question is
and get involved by the way with
hashtags feet chest which chess player
would you like to see a documentary made
about and we have to go to the games
because the games are underway here and
we have Teddy Coleman with the black
pieces alina couch the sky with white
Danya we have the triangle so Teddy
going for this approach again but
perhaps Selena now that she's seen Teddy
playtest against levy Rosman she'll be
well prepared here yeah I mean this is
such and we discussed this then this is
such a theoretical line there's Bishop
f8 in this position a cute-looking move
of course King takes f8 not possible due
to checkmate I mean I actually tried to
study the slide once and I took one look
at some of the game annotations and
megabase and I thought this is not for
me there is so much theory in this line
and of course White's acts upon a
compensation is pretty evident to
bishops initiative but if black
consolidates he could end up being
better and aleena already taking a deep
thing here I'm not sure whether the
theory has ended or whether 97a
surprised her I think you know more
about this position than I do Robert
well I mean Teddy has played this before
against Larry Rosen and you just take a
peek of this position you see that black
is temporarily up upon the Queen on e4
stairs at g2 which you know it's
someone's you want to capture in other
lines that just helps a white develop
but here the rook is saved by trick2g I
was wondering if he if Teddy could have
played Queen takes g2 but this is a
highly theoretical line just showing the
analysis board really quickly after
Bishop takes g7 Queen takes g2 must be
tempting because you're hitting the
bishop on g7 as well as the rook on h1
and so it's kind of a rook trait of on
h8 and h1 but the players know what
they're doing it seems like Teddy moving
so quickly that he went rook to g8 so he
must have had this still in his
repertoire
I mean Danya an extra minute plus thus
far for teddy here does that spell some
kind of problem for it does and and at
first I thought Elena would move her
bishop away but black and his Queen
takes Shih Tzu followed by Queen 61 idea
so queen g4 on the board and I feel like
this is way but what about Queen g2 now
yeah oh my goodness and the g7 bishop is
hanging wait a minute aleena probably
intends to cast along there but how
about 97 in that position that's what I
was wondering if I can just close down
the D file and your rook on h1 and your
Bishop on g7 still under attack as one
mr. Bartholomew would say man man man
I'm just losing after Queen takes she's
yummy with these positions it's never
entirely clear cut because of the Kings
safety but if that D file is plugged I
don't see how white saves a piece he
either loses g7 or he loses h1 yeah and
she I think Alina has miss played this
and Teddy going to a deep think it's a
critical moment to do some dairy but he
doesn't see too because why don't you
yeah one more thing I was going to say
was if instead of Castle queenside
Bishop f6 Queen takes h1 Queen d6 there
are some sort of mating necks like this
where I'm hitting the e7 square and your
Knight can't move because of d8 so that
was one thing to keep an eye on but even
there I think black is doing well in
some of these lines where you sacrifice
your queen to save your king sometimes
you can for example on g5 and now this
97 move stopping checkmate in one and
putting these square f6 in some trouble
but I think that'll Mina can still try
something this right so after let's say
you play the move Knight d7 here because
you have six Queen h1 Queen d6 this
Knight can now move out the way that's
the important thing about having problem
right night at five exactly so I move my
attack piece and I still protect the
square and life continues but 97 and the
question is does Wieck have any way to
prolong the game to create any sort of
resources against Plex King and I just
don't see it Robert I have one for you
Bishop e5 Queen to the Queen takes h1
Bishop f3 but then you go Queen takes g1
and just right and you mentioned that
right black gets a full house for the
Queen I give them for a horse right I
mean to
in a piece now the game is not over
there I think that probably is white
that's a good catch but Bishop f6 played
first of all Black has tonight at five
Intermezzo to think about but I'm not
sure that's necessary and that's a
really good point that you're making
here Danya and one that I think we you
know even even us and we think like we
do I throw in that mover should I
reserve it because at the Queen d6 I
always have this Knight a5 move and so
unless there's a clear benefit by
attacking this Queen it's just a one
move threat so I don't know if I would
play Knight a5 here Queen takes each one
feels just super natural because I'm
stealing a rook off the board I don't
see a checkmate for why to take
advantage of just yet and Teddy is deep
in thought here because this is a game
he does not want to spoil yeah
especially with the black pieces to have
such a chance out of the opening he does
decide on that f5 now we know that Teddy
has a bit of a predilection for safer
position see he doesn't like undue risk
but oh my goodness what a move Oh oh my
goodness oh my gosh my that is nasty
oh and that's and you call it Robert you
mentioned don't make these unnecessary
moves there's a sick then a sick that
using brilliance do you have to play 97
back Queen d5 there's rook takes d5
can't block the D file wait Queen d5
what well I Oh Queen da that's also made
oh goodness let's just try there's so
many threats
I forgot Queen d8 is also a threat but
we're just 97 back and I know it's not a
movie you want to play but the point are
you have a seven Bishop e7 then I take
your queen because now your Bishop was
right under alright yeah so the question
is an amazing idea but his whites so
losing and look at that Teddy takes his
time he finds 97 per turn that is a
brilliant shot by Alina I would say 7
now Robert yeah every 67 probably move
you have to play but then Bishop takes
d7 and you're not worried about your
back huh I know you lose some of your
Queen side but this rook on each one is
still hanging there and moves like
Bishop f3 I still play Queen h1 fish of
h1 group G one check and I continue
picking up all your pieces and the two
rooks in a minor piece for
weed is too much so queasy seven ancient
ford but what next Queen T's yeah then
night at five
I guess Queen H once she wants maybe
Knight f3 and Rose G one but discuss
Queen takes you want in that Bishop on
f6 will fall at the end adding insult to
injury well is there some kind of weird
draw Queen h1 Queen d6 Knight f5 Queen
c7 and just like hahaha we're singing
the night to come back to e7 yeah that
sounds like an alpha 0 against stock
fish game with one of those drawers so
the question is after Queen d6 and if
black plays I suppose Knight g6 you can
still go Queen see some of it isn't
add anything for black what a game I'm
mesmerized by this early on fireworks
now Queen b6 I can't get over how
beautiful that move is we were joking
before we started the actual chess here
that you know we were not in a serious
mood but the players are putting us in
one because we're here not analyzing
these crazy tactical variations how do
you cover the d8 square in Queens xf2
Teddy playing for more here is I'm not
sure about that move that there's
something about that that doesn't look
that doesn't sit well with me Bishop d4
by alina look at the time situation
Bishop e6 Robert that's a huge threat oh
my gosh you just packed me six square
who would have thought that it plays
such a pivotal role in this game but it
does so maybe Queen h4 just so you can
move your night out the way once there
should be six him so queen of five not
seeing the danger isn't Bishop e6 now
but a queen g5 chunji my jack and by the
skin by the herons his chinny chin chin
Knight f3 Knight a5 then Knight f3 that
still looks scary yeah
white cleared picking up the momentum
this is very scary stone i defiantly is
also something to be considered covering
the g5 square preemptively in time
pressure that's a very hard enough to
deal with as well if they're Knight of
three I might blame like Knight g6 to
get Queen up for check-in I would love
to trade Queens because I see that your
Queen on c7 is trying to checkmate me
and this Bishop d6 move I mean this that
just looks good you're threatening this
mate on d8 here and Queen g5 is we were
discussing seems to be the only way to
stop it I guess actually can put f6 Oh
me me me Bishop e6 F says he has it
escape with your king this way but
that's I mean haha sorry go ahead
I was just gonna say I would maintain
that after something there should be six
f6 practically speaking
Helena's gotta try to stay up on the
clock here so maybe Knight f3 then but
the thing is even if they can get staff
7 even if black takes on b6 the
initiative continues and Alina does go
for Bishop e6 yep
now Teddy has this choice between g5
checker up 6 and Teddy has deep in
thought you see his posture here head
and hand trying to figure out I mean how
do I even survive the next three moves
I've 25 seconds on the clock Queen d8
checkmate is threatened I think he plays
cause he's with Queen g5 and Brooke D -
I'm not sure about rookie - I don't like
pinning my own Brooke but at the same
time it says she's clever because now
Knight of three Brooke h2d one and the
Queen can't stay pinning the rook and
defending the d8 squares 1 7 whatever
one King move anyone I've is also
possible but I love her of T 1 because
if 92 b6 is rook e8 check me f6 feels
absolutely 5 is gonna be quickly via
crusher f6 you need to make space turkey
rook cheat you know 905 95 then takes
eat to call simply rook takes c2 right
okay and here it is rook TC - you have
to I feel like yeah you have to try it
but three seconds for Teddy and just
literally to see - the problem is you
still can't take on e5 but maybe take on
b6 you take on b6 Queen b6 why is up in
exchange for two boons Robert Ricky - 96
with da oh you're so that is so sick
that is oh it's miss we have to pull pin
now six but she misses her tiara just
happens you know any white show that
rook da check Queen takes he'll only
move Queen takes f7 is check and mate on
this black King and it doesn't matter
because she wins by he wins I look at
that Queen swinging from b6 did you won
- GA
what a game oh my gosh oh my gosh that
was you know Alina catch the sky funny
Queen b6 Teddy didn't see that at all
that I promise you
and once she found that move it was
pretty much game over so you know a bad
opening for Alina because Teddy knew
what he was doing and got an objective
advantage but she handle it so after
that point got a head on the clock and
Teddy just you know if you know what to
do is fluster the position is difficult
and it was Lee
who ends up ahead incredible and I'm
actually and again this is my daily
compliment for you Robert so please
cherish it you mentioned before a night
at five that in these types of positions
you don't wanna you don't wanna play
with fire if you have a move that's good
and you just take the rook take the rook
because you never know what kind of
resources you might allow if you try to
get a little bit too fancy but Queen b6
just incredible what a beautiful
concepts and what an incredible
follow-up
yeah these lines is dangerous in that
last game for black no matter what even
if you do escape with some material and
here in this game
White has already pushed his pawn to h6
olena Chuckster bishop back in tha and
the long-term elements of this position
is is this Bishop nature ever getting
out right because it's not just about
going for checkmate
you have the g7 square cover it so
you're not getting checkmated but in
certain end games with your bishop so
stuck on a useless diagonal that can be
a big issue especially as the weak
square tends to be d6 and if y can pile
a pressure on that square the vishal nh8
not really helping defend against some
lone white trash dodge my King's Indian
Bishop Robert I'm just I'm just making
sure that you're honest with yourself
well I've played the Kings Indian for
maybe 17 years I'm anything but honest
in itself and I can probably write a
book I mean we try to feature all the
games where I lost due to that h8 Bishop
basically King hemmed in so the key
priority for black here is to
orchestrate Queen side counter play as
quickly as possible that is exactly what
Elena's trying to do Knight g5 securing
the e4 square e for fun now the computer
always evaluates these positions that's
better for white but black always has
play connected with b5 that's the nature
of the continuum that's what makes it
such an attractive opening especially in
blitz I'm totally with you down you know
I think that the King's Indian and
classical chess you don't really see it
too frequently at the highest levels
because there are inherent risks to plan
the Kings Indian some structural issues
mostly on some Queen set initiative for
white but this isn't that kind of Kings
Indian where white is the only one
playing on the Queen side he gets c4 c5
no black is actually she's well
positioned with the rook insane Queen d1
one of the prudent moves being like well
I don't like this pin
the Queen on c2 perhaps over some kind
of night a for at some moment or b5 as
you were mentioning now b5 still under
White's control for the time being and
night to e8
so her idea is standard Kings Indian let
me push that f-pawn but donít let me ask
you is it entirely safe to push that
f-bomb because what we'll play b4 and
then a 96 type of maneuver and does feel
like the black king is becoming more
vulnerable as soon as you touch this
f-bomb yeah it's definitely not safe and
and black might have an idea of going
after six first but that always creates
the problem of a potential positional
sacrifice on e6 I'm not saying that's
what White's gonna do but I'm with you
Robert f5 with your King on g8 like that
and upon an h6 like that I've done that
before very very dangerous so I actually
think maybe f6 is an idea for black and
Elena's just annoyed at that night on g5
Teddy's definitely better here I think
there's no doubt about that
but here we see again the practical
difficulties of playing this with with
white for example if you played before
just to give an example of the kinds of
resources Black has 96 a3 rook takes c3
and that actually might happen on the
board Teddy's got to be careful Oh rook
takes rook takes any misses it oh my god
I just wanted to give an example
you called in after rook takes c3 the
best that white has some kind of knight
takes h7 just you're gonna lose your
knight anyway because your bishop is
overloaded protecting both knights and
so 90 x h7 at least gains you another
pawn for your trouble a knight takes f7
so I can't believe that happened that I
was just saying you know just as an
example yeah you are the Prophet that
Teddy did not need today
definitely not I think you just which
point you take the f7 b h7 hmm I would
take the h7 fun because taking the f7
pawn actually favors black by opening
that file now it's important to point
out that night on a6 is very passive so
the game is very far from over
now white is the one with serious
practical chances I would say I don't
know maybe maybe taking up seven to stop
at five ideas that's what I was thinking
because you know if I take on f7 rook F
seven bishops e3 you put your Queen on
f6 I play f3 just close down the F file
and I will concentrate all of my
attention on the Queen side is white
because but can't really make easy
progress in the King so you can play g5
g for especially up to an f3 maneuver
and that makes sense that's in the style
of a King's Indian but white will start
pushing on the Queen side and while
there's no exact target just yet it's
something that it won't be easy for
black to me he decides to take on h7 and
then f5 comes and I think blacks king is
now very safe and you're making headway
on the Kings side so this position is
turning south very quickly for white
alina tactically alert and we just go
back one more time to some of a3 Queen
b3 was clearly far better protecting the
pawn on b4 and the knight on c3 so know
this rook c3 business would have been
available to alina so unfortunately for
teddy he was not aware that rook takes
if there was a threat and for Lina I'm
showing good tactical vision Queen b6 in
the first game brooke takes you three in
this one and this one still will
continue because although we like blacks
position in blacks time advantage the
King on h7 if you play f3 g4 for whites
swing the Bishop to d3 there are some
challenges for the black King but okay
going out to d5 because very notice the
confidence in Elena's place she's up two
and a half minutes on the clock
that is incredible now b5 Queen e8 is an
idea that d5 pawn is more important than
it might look if it falls blacks gonna
have that pawn face in the center that
Knight can jump to have four I feel like
that might be the key to the position so
I like b5 obviously that's not for
Selena could make a neutral move like
Queen e7 connecting her pieces she does
go b5 and now Queen a and she does it
and g4 bishop c apis should be 7 is an
idea you know even brigham c8 here i
like bishop c8 you're just going after
this pawn on d5 and there's no way for
what to really protect it so that seems
like a very important pawn to win and
die knowing you're just calling
everything right now and the Lina cash
and skya she is making the most of her
narrow did ski like me but I don't mean
to be a Mexican when I watch football
games sometimes Tony Romo's doing the in
the commentary and he always spoils the
play before it happens and he this is
gonna be a this type of run the over end
back this kind of past and that's
exactly
what happens but you've taken the fun
out of it so although I know battery my
predictions IgA by Alina in the spirit
of of Bishop CA maybe she's trying to to
potentially clear the pieces off the F
file in case of g4 that's perhaps an
option I was gonna say if you're really
going full tony romo you're gonna have
to call me Geum you know I come on Jim
you look at that Funimation there and
while we do look at the formation here
black has a situation where it's two
nights for rook and pawn but the
position is closed for now so what
chances does Teddy have maybe g4 maybe
f4 trying to open up some space for the
rooks the rook can go to c1 at some
moment in the near future and the
downside of playing move like b5 done I
think you'd agree is that you've given
up the c6 square for instance so if I
can play rook c1 move my picture out the
way over c6 then the d6 pawn feels weak
White's doubling on the C file only
White has two rooks so if you can double
on an open file that gives you all the
chances there because black can't fight
for it in the same manner and yeah I
don't like agreeing with you but I have
to begrudgingly admit that was well
explained yeah and I mean this F for ID
is actually very very annoying because
if the dark squared bishop disappears
from the board that's a serious problem
for blacks king there's Queen D for
Queen eight Queen g7 idea so I would try
to eliminate that age six fun Alina is
probably trying to swing her Queen to h4
which is a very sensible idea I think
Teddy has no time to waste he's gotta
play a four he's got to do something
right now he's thinking too much right
now because it's also going Queen eight
back to d8 watch out for the a7 square
at time the Queenie three shifting your
focus to the Queen side hits a7 and says
what you have to worry about that went
to Bishop f6 she's lining up her Queen
and Bishop Bishop g5 coming and then she
finally looks good and there we go g4 by
Teddy he's got to try something like
this I'm just not sure what he gains
from it yeah I don't think he's getting
much either
an f4 egg you know you give him the
vintage for wins now ah still not over
Bishop siege okay but he has no he's got
no time either so Wow Alina
jumping out to a 2-0 lead incredible
tactical confidence here if you're Teddy
how do you handle this situation I mean
you're repeating alignment
new better than Elina did just buy her
time usage but maybe you know lena
racked her brain during that first
ambition of a fate we talked about this
move because you can't take on a fate
because queen D is checkmate but Teddy
faced that against levy in the
quarterfinal match of your response will
still be 97 but to answer your question
Daniel I mean Alina is still thinking
here right so clearly Teddy feels more
comfortable in this opening so I liked
his return to it he definitely knows he
spoiled some good chances in game 1 and
for Alina you need to fix the opening
stage because she's an out plain teddy
after the opening that's for sure
right and well I'm a little bit
surprised that she repeated this lining
given that she didn't have something in
mind as an improvement it might be very
well be that she prepared several moves
in this position and she's just choosing
one maybe she's playing a little bit of
a psychological game you know sometimes
you don't want to play too fast in order
not to reveal the extent of your
preparation maybe but all your opponent
into thinking that you're not well
prepared but I like her choice here
she's not giving up she - I mean in this
case you know the white is gonna have at
least some compensation right and I'm
gonna put a 1 a 3 to permanently
prevent black from castling you can't
castle through check even if you see 5
that is a committal move but one that is
sort of standard you guys look at this
Bishop on a 3 now Dona it's not really
doing all that much and eventually this
night on g8 will come to c6 for instance
you Castle kingside and I it's
interesting that we turn from a really
crazy razor-sharp tactile game into a
positional one where black is up a pawn
but this Queen on e4 it looks nicely
centralized but it becomes victim to a
quick attack Bishop d3 rook e1 that kind
of stuff and that's why we tell people
you don't want to move your queen too
many times in the opening because it's
easy to attack and gain 10 B for white
now that the Queen's on e4 so Teddy is
now down on the clock alina played a
more positional approach in dunya what
do you make of this position
I like Teddy's position here I think I
am on the same page that the queen is
experiencing some discomfort but in the
event of something like rook e1 the
Queen could also tuck itself on c6
and potentially combined to the bishop
battery and here we're gonna see Elina
forcing Teddy to decide he goes Queen of
four okay so maybe he's trying to get
the Queen to c7 later on but that we
could sit on that for for the time being
now Teddy has this plan of flowing b6
and Bishop e7 and although I does have
the two bishops and you know White has
some initiative left I feel like if
black castles and puts a rope on g8 I
don't know how big I don't know about
you Robert but I don't think White's got
full compensation for the plan oh yeah
I'm in serious trouble here I tend to
like these seven positions for black
because I am greedy I like the extra
pawn but in particular it's not easy to
see a concrete way that what has
compensation and what do you mean by
that wouldn't we look at games we see an
imbalance of some sort we say oh this
vague term compensation but what does
that really entail well you you wanna
have a clear plan you want to have a
target to exploit you want to have an
advantage somewhere White's advantage is
having a dark square bishop while black
does not but you know she's trying to
play ninety five and maybe use this
bishop but the knight on f6 is such a
strong piece blocking the scope of this
Bishop on b2 and even if you eventually
capture on f6 and I have to take with my
cheap on well that's okay with black
this is sort of a French like structure
where you have the pawn on e6 the bishop
on b7 but the difference is now that why
is that you down upon in a kind of
French dynamic so I like blacks chances
just like you do I don't see a clear
weakness to exploit I don't see a target
and while we talk upon structure a five
to eight for Danya female well there it
is somatic tuned on us to open up the a
file and Lina responded very well there
should be one covering the a2 square but
that's what you tend to want as black
when you have this sort of punch Archer
a5 a4 break open the a file yeah and I
mean insofar as white is going to try to
whip up some sort of initiative those
two bishops I've heard them referred to
as Horowitz Bishop's in sort of Russian
chess literature I don't know if anybody
knows that term but those bishops
can potentially contribute to an attack
so Felina puts an IG five is a very
serious sort of tactical idea here
because it could be followed by Knight
takes f7
I would actually seriously
h6f IRA Teddy here to restrict that
night because his kingside pawn
structure is not as solid as it may
appear or maybe Queen back to f4 but
it's a g5 as you were talking Danya I
was saying Queen up for as well just
putting that Queen back on the score -
even threatened Bishop takes f3 to ruin
White's King side pawn structure Queen
of force played so that is the very
teddy like move safe not committing to
anything on the King side but also very
practical and strong I would think about
95 in response for Alina but the problem
playing 95 is your opening up the scope
of my Bishop on b7 so unfortunately for
Alina she doesn't have the same solid
footing on the f6f-3 square as black
door f6 is so well defended for black
given night there at pawn on g7 white
only has that one pawn on G to it so she
does actually play 1985 but 95 Bishop e5
Queen to g5 type of thing going for the
African and then black is the one who
starts to develop an initiative against
White's Kings so this is in that a file
you pointed out earlier Robert that's a
very forward-thinking idea by Teddy
because that could come into play if
white fully extends herself to defending
the Kings side potential rook
infiltration to a3 do I mean I'm talking
far in the future but you know that
could could play a role as well so
definitely very successful opening by
Teddy but he's taking a lot of time here
maybe he's a little bit worried about
some Bishop c7 ideas if you allow the
Bishop to g5 but I don't think it's
anything to worry about
I don't know maybe he's think about
Queen g5 immediately he's got to be very
careful that flock and he does it and
qui g5 is extremely smart just for the
reason you laid out if 95 Bishop e5
incomes at Bishop c7 with the tempo
hitting the royal King the b-pawn
because Queen g5 isn't by F for
simultaneously protecting g2
in attacking the Queen so that's what
about a port here sorry to cut you off
rubber
no no probs I was thinking about that
but that's a really risky decision to
play out for because I can take on that
for and you're gonna try to go to Knight
takes f7 on me but is there actually a
mate to follow tonight if seven king of
some Queenie 16 of Fame's like you're
inching forward on my baby 7 yeah but I
see what you're saying it one single
move and black Ward's off the Queen DJ
Ward's off the Queen and number one
today in white his loss so Alina decides
to go for the longer term sort of game
and now again Bishop c7 potential idea
actually a little bit more unpleasant
than I think I gave it credit for
initially and one more thing is that
black would consider rook takes d1 rook
takes you when Bishop takes f3 here
distracting the Queen from the defense
at the bishop but the rook on a8 is
hanging so that's one of those important
things where it looks like you're
winning upon because you distract the
Queen away from 25 but then you
blunder your rook in the corner so
tactics need to be fully thought out and
not just saying hey I I got what I
wanted by winning a pawn now the rook
even though look a Brooke now looks well
defended it's easy to overlook this
especially in blitz that after all the
dust settles I no longer have a defense
for that rooks with Bishop c6 played
it's Bishop c7 idea Danya yeah I don't I
mean even in the immediate leadership c7
rook takes rook rook takes rook and then
why just wants to collect some pods on
the Queen side and ask like you know how
are you going to either take advantage
of that weakened White King I I mean
especially given that Teddy's got 40
seconds Bishop c7 is very practical
decision here but obviously not for
stole Enoch and you know there's maybe
king h1 but I feel like she's got to do
maybe she wants to take on d8 first but
then there's rug d2 right that's the
exactly what I do not want to allow rook
da da Bishop c7 thinking you're being
more forceful but rook t2 comes and
you're like wait a second there's a
quick counter-attack and it's not
checkmate but you don't want to give
black that kind of play there so she's
thinking she's have a minute on the
clock done in her time management has
been stellar and Teddy properties
p'shone c6 to also allow 97 and keep
that score defendant and if you ever do
get Bishop takes b6 I've rook b8 perhaps
with the tempo down the B file you take
b6 + c5 she can take C try my Queensland
g5 but you think b6 I'm gonna try to win
b3 in return correct that's actually a
good point yeah that befell is now open
and here we see Bishop c7
I do think Teddy would would be playing
a little bit faster I feel like he's a
little shaken
given the turn of events in the first
two games and Alina goes Bishop e5 she
backpedals a little bit
would totally go for repetition here if
I were white I would just go Bishop c7
immediately and force black to be the
one who decides do I repeat do I not
repeat that takes another chunk off of
his clock if he decides to play on and
it's a good psychological question is
for teddy do you feel like I need to win
this particular game because I'm down
two points and I'm up a pawn so I have
that going as well or I have 35 seconds
left I haven't really been playing well
in my time trouble because he's been the
only one who's been getting in time
trouble so I just make the draw get on
the scoreboard and I was down to games
games levy rows when I came back and won
that so maybe I have that kind of
history on my side so we have the
repetition and yeah I like it mm-hmm is
he gonna repeat and he does and you know
he sort of kicks the field tool you know
one might say oh you know this was his
chance he's up upon but again like you
said he looks at the clock he gets in
the scoreboard he has the white pieces I
think this is a very sensible decision
there's no need to go absolutely crazy
when you're down two points and
basically the rest of the match is still
ahead of you yeah and if we were to sum
this up maybe I'm not being a completely
fair but what I would assess this match
so far and you if you asked me I would
say that Teddy has won the opening
battle and nothing else and Alena has
you know she's played decently in the
opening especially her doing black but I
think we've liked Teddy's position out
of the opening all three games thus far
and now even in this fourth game as they
repeat the line we said white should be
better here you turn the engine but he
blundered this knight on c3 this is the
exact repetition of Game two of this
match and here Teddy played Queen to d1
and after night he ate b4 Knight a6 made
this mistake with Queen and didn't play
Queen b3 but now he can't play Queen b3
which defends both b4 and this knight on
c3 so I think this is there's an easy
improvement for Teddy and the line is
safe and sound for white as long as
you're not hanging pieces so once again
dunya maybe maybe I'm wrong here but I
do feel like Teddy's gotten the
advantage of the opening no he
absolutely has and you know it there's
an interesting dilemma psychologically
when you know you win a game in a
certain opening but you were worse out
of that opening repeating that opening
it gives you that reminds you
that last game so it gives you that good
memory but at the same time you want to
be objective so Alena it's interesting
that she's repeated both with white and
with black and opening that that landed
her in quite a bit of trouble by huh
Sandy's got to get out of his head here
and sort of realized that he is veteran
he goes Queen d1 interest like look what
Elina did she put a five so I'm saying
I'm not going to repeat that because I
saw an improvement for you and so I
don't want to get in the same exact
position those look he did the right he
did like we knew a lot scheme okay so 85
is the novelty yes it was the the new
move in from the earlier game and now 98
same plan but not aligned before so
easily I like what Elena's done in many
regards she's gained herself a tempo
then p3 that feels slow here but that
he's playing with fire again making that
knight on c3 vulnerable it would be
funny if you give Alina ghost 96 you're
you're a mean guy Danya oh thank you for
letting I didn't know that Robert you're
the first person who's ever said that to
me well you're you 96 the only purpose
of that move is they threatened rook
takes c3 once again not all of us can
generate multiple ideas with one loop
Robert just a mere mortal and Alina
reworking her Bishop from h87 I like
that idea a lot it might seem on Kings
Indian of heard say on fianchetto the
bishop but that Bishop on the shade as
you pointed out Robert was a sight for
sore eyes so now she's got g5 under
control as well frightened that's the
important square she can play f5 as is
needed and the pressure on e4 is going
to be a problem for white so
overextending on the Kings side like
this you put h4 age five age six that
spent some time you also brought your
Knight to g5 and to bring it back to f3
you brought your Queen to c2 and back to
d1 I mean that's a lot of Tempe here
that white is spent just shuffling
pieces around and to Elena's credit
she's made useful move she brought a
rook to c8 pawn to a5 which stops before
the bishop now comes to e7 so that f5
can happen without any sort of white
piece jumping to g5 it feels like you
know in this kind of position and look
at the clock Danya I mean I'm talking in
a position but the time is telling the
tale game after game I already like
blacks position but you can't be in this
position and down two and a half minutes
in the
mm-hmm and we think levy Rosman for very
generous rate thank you to international
master levy Rosman a warm welcome to
lobbies of yours I just think black is
better here I'm gonna go out on a limb
here and say even objectively we discuss
a lot of these positions
there's objective you know advantage for
wife a practical chance for black I
think here black is probably just
objectively better the question is what
do you take with Bishop f5 is tempting
because it comes with tempo but GF is
sort of more in the spirit of the Kings
Indian maintaining kind of the integrity
of the pawn structure right because
you're capturing towards the center and
this pawn h6 in the long run in endgame
that's a weakness not a strength so GTA
5 is standard it also opens up the G
file for blacks rook or Queen to start
an attack on the White King so Bishop
takes a5 though as you point out hits
the rook on on b1 also gives access to
the d3 square which sometimes is a
nuisance so I would probably take with
the Jeep on but I completely understand
her time spent on this decision she
takes the bishop so does that surprise
you or yes it actually does it because
after rook c1 another sort of downside
is well you weaken the e4 square and an
interesting thing is that if white ever
lends a knight on e6 even if he sacks
upon I mentioned this idea earlier but
with the pawn structure as it is that
could actually be a very unpleasant idea
especially if white then maintains
control over the d5 square so maybe she
has something in mind here maybe 93 so I
wouldn't say it's a mistake but I don't
know maybe this is this is also
perfectly fine I honestly don't think
there's such a huge difference it's not
it's not a game-changer okay and she
plays Knight f6 and I'm thinking Knight
g5 because you were talking about the e6
square Knight a four play interesting
actually I sort of liked them
interesting idea by mr. Baldwin yes
there are some delegation approves of
this choice 94 okay so Elena wants to
keep her Knight on c5 but Danya white
had less space so trading off these
Knights feels like it sort of helps his
position breathe a little bit nice green
Bishop e3 for instance right here just
hitting the c5 there it is
nice the Teddy Coleman was first strikes
again and the point is that now I'm
throwing to take on c5 in your ePHI pawn
is hanging if you ever play moves like
d6 just any time you push a pawn think
about the squares at weekends be six
weekends a six and C 6 and my bishop can
already go to b5 as is needed so I would
refrain from playing b6 for as long as
possible and Donny let me ask you take
on c5 here I
I mean intuitively I'm trying to make
sense of that line Bishop c5 DC d6
and Elena's definitely intending a force
a very concrete play but something
doesn't sit well with me there white has
95 in that position
I feel like Teddy should have taken that
night because now Elena can play maybe
b6 or move that night away entirely I
think the ship c5 was interesting I'm
gonna bring up the analysis board just
to show everybody because we're talking
ideas but it's good to show we'll deal
with on Bishop c5 the point is that you
know you have this pawn strip from the
Queen side three on to four black but I
have this past D pawn and Duensing oh
let me for now but 95 is such a nice
tactical idea the point is if you take
me on a five I have Queen d5 check
scooping up your Bishop and you need
that dark square Bishop to protect your
king
so white is pushing forward in the
position like this I like that idea but
I still like Teddy's position in the
game because he plays before and it's
sort of a standard like Queens pawn game
where white is very active and blacks
pieces don't look well coordinated that
the Queen b3 very circumspect as well
defend in the c3 square also notice that
pawn on h6 we discussed how it could be
both a strength and a liability but here
White's Bishop on e3 is kind of now peg
to that pawn that was another advantage
of capturing on f5 with a pawn in
certain positions black could play up
for intercepting and that's what a Lina
tries to do here but that introduces a
whole fresh set of weaknesses now that
Bishop on f5 salsa vulnerable oh look
look at that move by Teddy saying you
know you just push your Jeep on making
your King a little bit more suspect on
the King side I'm going to try to trade
off your knight which is so nicely
centralized and my name in f3 we just go
back one little half move here the night
after he's not doing anything it has
like no promise in this positions are
attacking a square so let me trade off
my knight that hasn't been very active
for your bed
peace and well what's gonna happen maybe
white will play d5 may even be six and
just try to take advantage of the
queenside a little bit because they're
to open files here the C file and the a
file and the pawn on b7 feels like an
eventual place I want to attack it's
very difficult to get to it but now that
Black has also exposed her King side a
bit it feels like Y can shift from flank
to flank a little yeah and aron
nimzowitsch sort of the founder of
modern positional chess talked about
what you just said where when you have
more space in your opponent as more
weaknesses one of the sort of hidden
advantages of that is you can shift you
know he calls it like a trampoline you
can jump from one flank to the other
very effortlessly where is the opponent
as too laborious lee shift his weight
from side to side and eventually you
could kind of get overextend root
overextended like that indeed and I mean
this Queen on e7 right it's protecting
g5 but you can foresee a time where
white plays b5 b6 and rook c7 giving up
a pawn on the c7 squared to distract
that Queen and here's be 500 Chow for a
counter attack though beyond 5 or we
know we all know how to what Elena's
capable of in the realm of incredible
tax resources so rook c7 maybe but then
Queen takes h6 already threatened
checkmate I'm not sure that's anything
to worry about the g3 but notice Teddy's
clock I'm getting a little bit stressed
about that time situation actually Queen
h6 does bother me because g3 would be
the way to stop the checkmate and the
Queen comes down to h3 setting up
sacrifices on the square
look at the clock he's got 10 seconds
ago this has to move he just has to make
a decision
oh my goodness he takes ok what's is a
you go rook c1 next c1 I think yeah but
still I mean Queen h6 still threatens
checkmate yep not the way he'll play g3
and that pawn and b7 there's Bishop a6
ideas to sacrifice my bishop to
Springfree the b-pawn and that's the
thing that happens in a position because
the black queen is distracted towards
the King side when some action out of
nowhere will happen on the Queen side so
watch out for a bishop a6 type of move
and h6 is hanging we both agree that
black is stealing a pawn but it's not
the whole story it's not just the
material count because black will still
be stuck the GG 5 pounds also room I
like that decision very practical yeah
Teddy's clock Queen takes age six now
for up c7 there's real k1 check
okay so Queen before threaten your entry
but allows Bishop D for some creases of
a bishop f1 about one okay but Bishop d4
becomes an option for okay Bishop
everyone there is for probably g2 just
okay that's a good defensive movement
either okay three but then rook rook c7
maybe maybe Teddy holds us together
maybe there's nothing but then Bishop
takes c3 rookie drop creates that I
would start with Bishop g2 just to stop
your threats I know what you're up to
but if you - one second okay oh my gosh
she played it with Luigi's every Bishop
before is an idea but doesn't quite work
because a Bishop g2 yeah you're trying
to check me me on each one but I always
have issues like two seconds in this
position is it's hard to know what this
is better I'm just but sorry but the
chest I like white but practically
because the time I like black okay
Bishop g2 he's making it happen he's
looking better next in Queen f3 there's
just king g1 that's nothing to worry
about per se right and she's now under
20 seconds left she cannot get down
under 10 seconds you don't want to have
a total times water oh my gosh he's
getting moves off barely Queenie three
seconds this next move this next moves
gonna be tough and yeah because you want
to pre move but have you pre movin oh
you got it we tried yeah but wait drive
then one game one they're swinging on
look c1 he's barely hanging on here and
she'd under 5 seconds she takes and
takes and probably just takes something
fine Gary
oh yeah quit c8 I would have given that
job with King g7
III okay we do you want Queen he wanted
me to wins
nobody's it Queen g5 oh it's that mean
official Queen six h7 okay goes Queen G
we know she left since she lets him
he lets her out of the cage King takes
b6 there's always than king b5 and
there's nothing to worry about now yeah
you couldn't this is not the way to do
it
oh my goodness out her king has escaped
and yeah blogs are two minute cones and
black doesn't even need to focus on
promoting I mean she can just win slowly
and that's exactly what happens Wow
wow that is a heartbreaker for mr.
Coleman and we see him leaning back in
his chair but in Teddy has demonstrated
resilience before sorry good know it's a
theme right
teddy is just getting himself into way
too much time trouble he's trying to be
perfect in his play before that moment
and he's had some rough positions he's
had some good positions but the point is
that he doesn't have time to calculate
when you really need to in some critical
moments in aleena I'm gonna bring up the
analysis board because I want to
highlight something she did in that last
game which you commended in the moment
and now that I have a little bit of time
to reflect it was so smart and the way
she won this game it doesn't look like
it from HS point of view but here on 36
rook c1 she did not trade rooks allow a
trade to liquidate she played rook to e8
saying I want to keep material on the
board you have 8 seconds left I have
over a minute and that cost of confusion
had Teddy's clock tick down to two
seconds and eventually she was able to
score the full point in his time trouble
so kudos to Alina Cashman sky
understanding the dynamic understand the
teddy is not really feeling good and
under the duress of these minimal
seconds on the clock so now we get to
the live position done I just wanted to
highlight that once more because I think
from a match strategy and a game
strategy point of view you were totally
correct to call that moment out yeah I
mean she just understand the problem is
the amount of decisions that White had
to make in time pressure one or two
Teddy made them but eventually you just
make a mistake with two seconds on the
clock
mathematically speaking if you have
seven tactical decisions to make you are
going to stumble at some point so here
we have the so-called Cambridge winters
variation also known as the Cambridge
summers if the Cambridge Springs but you
may get really I was likely to laugh in
to applaud my my humor here that was an
awful seasonal joke I didn't appreciate
it at all you were we were getting along
so well into that moment and what did I
what did I just do well you know it's
been what 45 minutes or so that I that
you held me in your good graces so I
think that's a record I thought you were
gonna make a you know kind of an easier
joke and since that Teddy went to
Harvard and that's in Cairo Harvard
Springs okay there you go
be something like that would have
Galerius just not funny at all but if
you were gonna tell a bad joke you might
as well tell one that makes no sense but
knight on e4 Bishop on h4 Danya we both
think I'm speaking for you a little bit
there's no attack just yet for white but
you see a knight f6 type of maneuver and
you have to pause you say all right is
that sacrifice coming and am I just
gonna get checkmate in over them the
Kings side or is black going to put tack
in quotes with a rook c8 and take over
the C file more quickly
I like blacks position again I mean
there's no attack that I see just yet
yes e-file is very important it really
all hinges on on whether or not I mean
white could be in very serious trouble
if if Elena doesn't find some sort of
attacking chances maybe what you do is I
mean I feel like that back Rankin could
cost white so maybe something like take
c8 and then go h3 and go Queen g4 and
hope for the best but if that Queen side
evaporates a p2 is gone I just I
honestly don't see it cuz Bishop f8 also
Robert is another defensive move that
could be played at the right moments
just basically covering everything I
think there's not enough horsepower
there's that fourth five ideas but
objectively I don't think White's got
enough here yeah at four or five it
feels like an all-in approach in 96 you
do you don't have to take but of course
you are going to take on d6 and now is
that pawn a strength is Bishop e7 coming
in to reinforce that pawn and white is
happy or is having a 27 and no
clear way to actually kick that night
from b7 nights are excellent blockading
pieces especially against a dark square
bishop because my Knights and a light
square your bishops on the dark square
you cannot attack my knight kick it off
this between 84 hit c2 hits d4 but
they're sometimes where white just gives
up the d4 pawn and with like a rook c1
to take over the open file so Diane do
you like this decision by Lina to trade
rooks or would I do
Oh trade ropes I don't see okay so what
was she worried about in the event of
Brooks - I'm probably the d4 pawn she
didn't want to lose the pawn but now
Teddy's got that down - over the phone I
actually don't like her decision because
this looks something about this just
doesn't look right maybe rook see -
maybe I mean if Teddy picks off that d6
fun then Elena's in very serious trouble
so as you pointed out everything hinges
on whether or not why it's gonna be able
to to tie yourself down to that one but
again that Queen so Queen f3 threatening
I guess potential
when ahx I don't know what to make a
disposition it's very complicate or know
how to evaluate it but to be honest I
think black is much better and the
reason why is you know I know you need
to kick my night out and push the pawn
but all the practical elements favor
black right I have a better pawn
structure despite the fact that this
pawn d6 is the most advanced pawn my
two-on-one on the queenside then may
become a 2 on 0 after rook takes a 2 for
instance that's going to be an issue for
white to deal with again if I trade
Queens I'm just pretty much winning
already so absolutely with those
connected passers and I like Teddy's
time management a little bit more he
made that decision rook takes a 2 with
enough speed now notice that Queen on a
for now defends the night on d7 I agree
Robert I think black is maybe even close
to winning now if he's careful yep and I
like Icelandic gambits comment the
computer loves black but this seems like
a difficult position to handle if he
gets in the time pressure again and
anybody can say to look an engine and
say oh this person must be better but
the why is essential and why we like
black as well didn't oh my god
Queen takes d1 oh it's a free roll by
getting with Czech that's that's what
Teddy needed huh that is exactly what he
needed he need to lean in a blender full
crook and I was just about to talk about
some of the elements the position but
the Queen on a4 did everything it
defended in 97 and detectives working d1
in help to be pawns progress
so Teddy bounces back aleena still up 2
points in the match but that must feel
good you know just to get your first
victory it does and we see Teddy would
be whoa whoa whoa
before what what's going on this is
overconfidence
I don't know Jesus I mean clearly he
prepared this foot
what is this Knight takes e4 94 they may
then maybe you take any five Queen e2 so
Elena believes him but even here he's
got to be careful not to overextend
himself but I guess there should be
three now well even move I don't I never
see I mean I'm not intimately familiar
with this line but and without divulging
too much about you Teddy Coleman's
repertoire I mean we are very close
friends I know he hasn't starting a lot
of chess recently and he was super
excited to play in this event and so
when Teddy plays like
for instantly it's either a horrible
mouth set when you went to an e3 or he's
prepared this it's not some you know
forgetful moment but you were correct as
well to say ephors risky just
strategically because look at the d4
square now if you're a Queen's pawn
player all right you say yeah what I'd
love getting my pawn on c4 d4 and e4
that's the best possible situation but
black can strike back well yeah c6 and
bring this knight in 2d for it because
you can't push your pawns backwards
that's a very committal decision right
and and you know this is sort of the
essence of I think what's called hyper
modern openings these people who
advocated for the Kings Indian in the
1920s for example they were they were
left out of the tournament you know what
are you doing giving a speech center but
eventually players realized that that
this idea of attacking a very vast fun
Center and of course I'm very biased
toward those types of openings because
I'm a king's Indian player but people
realize that you need to give those
types of openings very serious credit
but that being said I think White's
gotten a slight I mean Teddy has the two
bishops
as long as he can defend that e4 pawn
he's in pretty good shape here but
aleena can play Bishop h5 is from g6
Knight c5 comes into play it's a
position in the spirit of the Kings
Indian even though there's no fee and
keto dish bunchy seven even though it's
nothing like the King's Indians in the
spirit of the Kings okay so this is a
really key position done to bishops
against two nights aleena understanding
it hey the bishops don't really have too
much open space to work with but is
Bishop g5 and there it's played it's not
really about capturing on that six right
yet it's about either threat being
strong the execution but now the issue
maybe four oh I love that decision for
and just just go for checkmate gh4
so Teddy induces h6 and break this pin
and now after HX brings the bishop back
it's like wait didn't I just give black
a free move because I could have played
Bishop e3 right away black wants this
move h6 to h7 back this is an
interesting decision we've seen players
like Magnus Carlsen do that early and
sicilians and actually right now this is
like a reverse Sicilian in some ways
because well now the pawn structure
would now be fine I'm not sure about
this because Alina's also got this idea
of playing B 5 B 4 a 4 and then B 3 that
also comes very fast
hmm but she's prioritizing peace play I
would just go h4 here 9c for Bishop c1
I love positions like this work this
yeah this is gonna be a fascinating
finale I can just feel it there's gonna
be some fireworks shortly yeah Bishop c1
just G Fahd the bishops are so much
stronger y'all Knights in positions like
this because the Knights are all in on
the White King but the Knights do
nothing to protect the black King white
bishop on C one protects b2 while
allowing g5 to be punched through so
that just is a clear demonstration of
white bishop so strong g5 here I'm just
pushed in five what is the Lena antenna
maybe h5 but that just bites for some
time but I don't see an alternate you
cannot take on chief but that is just I
mean there's no way she's gonna get away
with this f6 but again
rook g6 rook g1 as you point out Robert
that Bishop on c1 for now it's serving
in defensive purpose on a moment's
notice it could leap into h6 and just
crush that g7 pond to bits oh my
goodness i don't know about hg i mean i
think after h5 you know the game
continues black and try to maneuver her
Queen to b5 there's still some attacking
chances now just looks almost like
checkmate on the cards and you know that
Teddy's feeling better because look at
his clock management he's actually ahead
on the clock
he is the position where he has an
attack point and you know one of these
lines that could happen as you said f6
will allow rook up 7 to defend g7 but
White's plan is still so easy broke g6g
1 Queen to h5 maybe then this rook can
swing from g6 to h6 and it's almost like
the easiest possible play for white
you've so many different options all of
them look good now sometimes that's you
know too many good options is a bad
thing but here it's a great thing
because Richie 6 rips you when you
didn't play h4 h5 h6 if you want to play
slowly because blacks attack well it's
not doesn't really seem like much of an
attack just yet
yeah and Teddy's gonna reap the rewards
of you know making moves like castlelong
quickly he earlier he took you know a
minute and a half two minutes on some of
these decisions now he said okay I'm
gonna make these decisions quickly they
might not be the best moves but it's
going to give me a lot of time for the
critical phase of the game but here I
don't think he should he should
overthink it I think rook cheese
thanks Brooke g1 as you pointed out
Robert that's just such an effective
plan you can also go rook h5 and try to
infiltrate that way but there's a small
danger that black will be able to run
her King and somehow we evacuate the
king although I highly doubt that as
well right that's a kind of a pipe dream
is king upset by ei King d8 running that
Queen King excuse me but doesn't look
very likely and Daniel what do you think
he's considering here's a rook g6 rook
h5 as you mentioned I mean made for
treating rook g3 just helped over
protect the a3 square and the b3 squared
but he does invention 56 and how do you
stop as a rookie
I mean rook g1 z1 yeah Bishop Aish I
think many many roads lead to Rome in
this position also rooked you won Queen
f5 and rook h6 is another idea and then
Queen h7 is devastating yep also that c8
broke sad insulted that's also
undefended so that could throw you could
be thrown into the mix no this is just
uh absolutely overwhelming again the key
for Teddy not to overthink it just go
rook shoot one and save himself a little
bit of time for the moment when he has
to calculate sort of the decisive
continuation and he must be considering
h4 some of that because otherwise rook
g1 is the move it's so natural here
blacks attack is very far off and the
bishop on c1 why talked about being a
multi-purpose piece defending b2 b2
doesn't need defense it's only attacked
one time by a knight they're funny to
defend it already yeah and he plays H
FRA I knew that's what he was
considering and I it's probably a good
move but it feels slower I agree Robert
I think there was just me if he had Gunn
wrote you one and then Quin h5 h6 I felt
like that was just me and I like Elena's
move a lot because Queen c7 says wait a
second of my Knights move out the way
you're Bhishma 1 C 2 will be hanging and
each five oh my gosh there's some
tactics that start storm clouds to start
gathering around White's gay but Elena's
got basically two moves to whip
something up here right and the moves
are you know we likely are considering
there's like a Queen b6 just that hit B
2 right away or a knight move away from
the C file so that when the next
moves BC to Bishop is hanging but Donnie
even that doesn't seem like it amounts
to much at all yeah it's very artificial
I mean if you go night a six o night be
okay good whoa what a move so a B she
wants like 90 to check yep what an idea
but I don't think it works but still and
the reason why it shouldn't work is this
Bishop takes B exactly and then you take
the Queen on b3 I don't wanna open up
the definitely yeah take on b3 and you
know that we can always swing back now
h6 once again is a huge threat so kudos
to Alina that was you know she's showing
some grit but I just don't feel like
there's enough firepower to mounts just
a serious resistance and here she tries
to compact her King
you keep you take with the bishop on h6
Brooksie warning right but then like you
know six in ArcheAge seven well you
don't know teddy Coleman like I do
clearly because he takes Bishop h6 was a
three which is I mean the most defensive
you can possibly get here Brooke h8 can
be played the ready six rookie to throw
ends rook takes h6 so that would be a
rook eight seven does the same but the
problems rook h7 is you don't really
threaten forget chicks cuz then rook g7
check is a counter strike against your
queen yeah I mean I would consider going
Queen b6 with black and not because that
endgame is is anything resembling
defensible but I feel like from a
psychological perspective sort of
winning a long endgame is a bit of an
unpalatable prospect three six chiseling
his way into that position we doesn't
have enforced
I thought Queen she was a big blunder to
some kind of Knight takes a three or
something like that but the thing is the
Queen still defends the third rank but
then would caught me off guard and I
went full Ric Flair with a rule but what
can take on d7 played Bishop g7 and
windy have six pawn or is that means
yeah but this is what I met what I would
I met you know I think in his mind Teddy
doesn't want it any kind of endgame you
know I agree Robin
that's just completely overwhelming but
but so is this now White's King is
pretty safe for up to seven is an idea
he's just got to be a little bit careful
and for Ali and I would consider King da
I mean just at all costs evacuate the
king force white to beat you in a
slightly different way and there it is
king d8 how about so if I move my Bishop
to g7 90 to check so you don't want to
forget then that is the right rook c1
play that block against King c7 that's a
brilliant move actually it really is
just look g8 take on c8 and then try to
pin this Knight and win it that I mean
looks pretty forceful yeah it cooked me
some filet mignon on c4 I mean and
that's something that that takes a lot
of foresight to realize okay not to have
that tunnel vision where you only think
about how to give checkmate you also
realize that you can use the crippled
position of your where's the mate though
where's their meet Bishop that's oh
there's my oh my goodness Rock h1 and
the bishop that fade was a really nice
idea of Queen g7 okay there's plenty of
ideas I knew you wanted to go for
somebody that but I think this is oh
wait he just hung a piece oh my goodness
we have six oh my goodness for the
rookie seven rookie 7 and then Bishop
Murphy you've had but 92 bishop f8 92 oh
gosh this is just getting done the Queen
e7 the Queen d7 oh please same thing
when I don't say TSU oh my goodness
Teddy blundered in time trouble this was
such an excellent game it was rook up
seven now he's you look for no cup and
said no he does know why he's gonna
checkmate him
oh that's heartbreaking goodness that's
I mean that could I hate to call things
our elite Danya no you're right you're
right the match that was ugly at one
point match now it's a three point match
and we are gonna have to bring that game
up in the analysis poor it's just go
over which is either didn't even see
what I took me a while to to register
what happens when we're bringing up in
the analysis for to show everybody that
after Queen rook to g8
rook g7 after King d8 he spent only a
second really two seconds on Queen g6
forgetting that once the King left the
seventh rank the rook on g7 was fully
under attack and so he just hung a piece
in the position and well he couldn't
even take on e7 next because it looks
like you're
one night but 92 check actually picks up
the rook on c1 that is bad news for
teddy we're gonna go through the live
position because we once again are in
these theoretical waters but the night
is already on that five here for black
so I mean a put our Bishop into D six
and then back to a3 giving white a tempo
with 97 f5 so what do you make of this
position Dell again we have a similar
structure this time aleena can first of
all take on that five endo Queen d6 and
stop black from castling that's one idea
this is definitely an improved version
of what we saw two games ago I mean
White's got more Tempe but I I'm
generally skeptical of these types of
positions because I feel like blacks
very close to consolidating but to go
back to what just happened I think Teddy
might have made the second move of the
variation I think he intended to give a
chat first
and maybe just forgot to do it that
happened sometimes absolute absolute
heartbreaker so you know Teddy seems
very composed he's he's very hard to
break and we've seen him prove his
resilience in his crit match after match
so we'll see that has to come into play
right now if he wants to to keep this
under control
and this positioning is pretty scary
because by inviting this Knight to f5 so
in that other game that night was on f6
right now it's an f5 but with the men at
five they're always opportunites for
what to capture on a5 I'll play d4 and
kick this night away but g4 is one of
those double edged moves that is quite
risky because you're pushing upon in
front of King so Lina plays Bishop c1
forces a taste Queen back and then plays
Bishop b2 saying it's better for white
that the queen is in a more defensive
stance on c7 than the active one on f4
and now once again 95
so she's paving the way for the Queen to
come to g4 the problem is let's say
Teddy takes only five of those Queen c7
there's Bishop b4 as well so there's
definitely you know more palpable
compensation here then then you know the
last time they reach the second position
I don't know what you think but I feel
like here whites it's still probably
insufficient but practically speaking it
feels somehow a little bit more
dangerous for black it does but I also
somehow liking blacks that have fun you
learn more at first I was like oh that
can be a loose piece but it just totally
stops White's attack because you have no
threats in the h7s we remember in the
previous game the bishops on b2 and b1
we're staring at the white I've seen the
black King side and it still seems to be
the case but a 9.5 not just blocks the
23 it protects g7 so but I like
this move because Queen age three after
Knight f6 creates more pressure on
blacks King side you're not wrong
that's what about some kind of I'm
certified a time as sort of queen c6
move but I I never gave it like 95 issue
from Queen c64 then you efficiently for
of course or Bishop f5 yeah oh yeah I
thought I was meeting you but you're
meeting me first
nice well you are meeting me except I've
got a queen on cheese what can somebody
can play Knight of 6 that feels like the
most natural yes Queen h3 yeah and then
your idea of g4 potentially can be
thrown into the mix there as well right
and that's actually very scary for black
because now all the white pieces staring
at the black cool okay now this is
either very good move or a very bad move
I think it might actually be a very good
move because 97 27 and Teddy's just
basically unloading all of this weight
from his position he's paying the price
you know in terms of the fact that II 6
is weak but I don't think it's something
white can exploit I'm with you and
actually you know in these lines where
even if you lose say a pawn buy a
capture an f5 at some moment you get
into an opposite colored Bishop position
where the pawn f6 is very useful because
look at this Bishop on b2 it's a lot
worse against this little pawn chain of
g7f 6:30 news with the pawn on f7 so
you're essentially saying that in the
long term this won't be - it has
less scope and so I will be willing to
even give you a pawn back on that five I
don't even see a way for Lina to win if
she she brings the knight back to f3 and
that's a good move yeah it's a the
frustrating move to deal with Queen c6 I
guess
yeah Queen sees but then Bishop before I
still as Bishop e4 stuff White's that so
many of these you know these tickle
ideas right
it's very easy very easy position to
blunder and also rook e8 rook takes c6
is a potential idea as well you know
rook e8 trying to give you know just
equalize the position give away that
pawn on f5 but I feel like rook takes c6
and be very strong essentially yeah
there if you move the effort you'll get
the f8 squared from your knight so
that's probably ah true but the
difficulty of moving the Africa is the
f6 pawn becomes more photographers
the 907 currently protects it there's a
pin down the G file but I'm always a
little nervous and he brings this from
does it what about your rookie six move
now I need to stop suggesting tactical
ideas because it seems to me every time
we give an example of a potential butter
Lina decides on Arkady won I'd like to
Ricky six I not seeing a necessarily
adequate response maybe Knight h6
against Ricky six but that doesn't look
that doesn't inspire confidence no it
does not and okay said rook e1 which is
the you know quote-unquote natural move
to play bring your work towards the
center another piece into the attack but
what black needs that one move to sure
up like some out yeah but you just get
that one move and you're like well now I
have no more weaknesses and I can turn
the tables but rook takes c6 still maybe
even bigger threat now I reckon exactly
now that everything is playing white
piece of whites position is just
breathing I mean every single piece is
coordinated very nicely which doesn't
mean that that blacks not better
necessarily fight you know it's probably
somewhere close to dynamic equality here
maybe this should takes up three and
ninety five is practical just I'm not
saying that's the objective best but
trading off a couple pieces is black
really gonna be at risk of being worse
with that d4 square for his Knight I
like 9h I was going to say 96 was
waiting for you to finish an e5 which
move e5 not so you're not scared of like
Bishop h7 over t7 you just want to move
your queen there
I am scared but I figured that at some
point getting a five was bad with rookie
seven spread way smarter than when I'm
away east 66 is even though Bishop f3
after 36 but then rookie seven oh gosh
this starting to get out of control look
at the clock aleem almost three minutes
ahead that is
and you see Teddy he dismissed it he
totally missed it but he plays rook ft
e8 and it's not the end of the world
because the knight of fate now okay
I just played out of fate I sure don't
get scared I'm not sure about rook ttohi
one I would have taken a little bit of
time there because Elena had tactical
ideas in that position and now there's
math trades and that obviously favors
white it favors white because of the
bishop pair but it favors black because
you're not getting checked me I'm sorry
I meant to say in famous black yeah I
just you spoke yeah definitely
Teddy will will sell his kingdom for the
rug trades along the e-file is there
some kind of rookie 7 rookie 7 Bishop f6
with the h6 night hanging okay so Rick
you sound like you're selling to strip
f6 I'll take on e1 you'll take and all
of whites pieces are somehow loose but I
can't quite put my finger on
maybe Bishop ca in that position yeah
but just Queen h4 I guess yeah I mean I
think that white gets away with it but
you're right white is feeling a bit
loose there but Elina very wisely
spending serious time on this move
because this Bishop f6 tactic after rook
e7 couldn't let her pawn yeah and it
could force Teddy to think rookie 3 I
liked it Alana's keeping at least one
pair broke something oh nevermind I was
freaking stricken off the record I'm
jamming disposition here no I know why
is the two bishops but I don't really
love White's position now no I don't
either
I agree hey Greg this party giving
yourself an isolated pawn on e3 I don't
love that
I think Elena was trying to plug that II
felt she was worried that her Queen on
h3
would be a little bit misplaced maybe
black at 27 ideas but I agree with you
Robert that's a pretty steep price to
pay and now that Queen comes to d6 it's
the same problem potential Queen
infiltration although why doesn't risk
of that yet well be sure it's to Bishop
C to this Bishop takes f3 and they still
gotta Queen d2 stuff oh we have to
though okay you barely get away with
barely bishop c6 we've seen setting play
this move before
sort of as I as a healthy waiting move
yep allows a 4-2
more of an option for Black Knight to d7
is protected there and black doesn't
really have any weaknesses to speak up
because the knight f8 on f7 that
combination is completely stopping honey
you know Elena liking that idea was in
doing Bishop c3 how about them apples
0:09 anymore
oh I don't like that move Robert that
move is okay so that was that was this
idea but even Ono h4 there's a knight
takes f3 and queen G Queen h2 check I
guess it's still quite good for black
yes but that move eight six from a point
point of view of a fisherman c2 aiming
at the king side I guess the 9 f8 covers
everything and without Knights you don't
care about scores I got 5 as much but
he's gonna trade Queens yeah he's
outgoing Teddy yep and bringing the king
in that means it's a reasonable
practical decision where is this
wants e3 gonna attack me the b6 square
would be the place but how you getting
your Bishop around I don't see it yeah I
mean black black is probably
symbolically better here but it should
be a draw game 3 3 and actually Teddy's
got to be a little bit careful because
King f4 and Bishop f5 check you don't
want to get too smug here because white
can snap on in 5 and go Knight g5 he's
got to be careful he's got 6 seconds and
g5 was played just in the bishop that
white needs is this dark square Bishop
to get active to hit the b6 pawn note
that all of black pawns are on dark
squares so that's what white desperately
needs to play for win but because the
king is not getting in a king f5 is
always in that h6 checker b7 I kicked
your King out at night I mean this is
just like a fortress yeah it really is I
mean I'm blocking in a couple seconds on
his clock just by shuffling
now if I really and I wouldn't try
something like Bishop d3 and then a3
before maybe because whenever you have 5
saying doesn't matter how drawn it is
you start getting nervous who wants to
play 5 yeah one second and putting in of
7 out of 7 oh my god goodness oh he was
so weird
[Music]
it's it's just painful it's painful at
this point he I mean night f7 is just
mmm and it's easy for for me to kind of
sit here and say but that is just that
can't you can't let that happen
especially when you're when you're this
down in the batch yeah he's just moving
way too slowly it's just he was kind of
one or two moves away from being minus
one in that not the last game with two
games ago he lost that game because he
blundered a piece and now he's in a
position where he just needs to get
victories and it's not enough to weep
for us to like his position at the
opening we've liked obsession on the
opening in most games at this point but
that last game you could tell he was
unconfident and when you blow positions
where you're winning you start not
trusting your calculating skills yeah
and unfortunate for Teddy it costs him
once more yeah it was a solid end game
that heat is normally so well-versed at
handling but he was just he was taking
these three four seconds where normally
he would basically play in silly
Andolini
for to her credit she's been keeping an
advantage in the clock pretty much every
single game and she's been very
tactically alert just the fact that she
put Bishop eat one bush wage for in that
position to give herself this idea of e4
e5 that was good vision and just she
posed enough questions and Teddy didn't
have all the solutions so what's going
on here Tania d5 and Aoife d4 and e4 we
have pawns aiming at each other I'm
going to confess the Robert as long as I
play the King's Indian I have never seen
move 7 b5 before I honestly don't trust
it entirely but you know we see again
already the time situation and Ally know
playing very fast like I guess it's kind
of a hacky a little gambit that she
prepared before the match interesting I
might take that into consideration all
right well we've seen some trade that
the d5 taking on e5 taken in d5 and in a
second I've seen this before
but I'm trying to fair wear because I
it's almost like a pond oh right same
issue with nicey 686 right at pond
sometimes sacrifice but I don't know
Teri's reacted in the best way well I
mean how does black it
full compensation you the bishop on g7
aiming at the opponent be - feels like
the way but isn't why just gonna play
should be for it well rocky eights
Bishop t4i Queen g5 was met with at four
oh yeah
so yeah this is a pawn can't dismiss
that and I think I actually looked at a
similar position with a student but
you're right that this doesn't come from
c6 b5 like this what about d4 here so d4
your idea is that if I take you with my
bishop and you have to take on f3 I take
you take on d4 we see a big series of
trades perhaps and then yeah black
certainly rook b8 at the end and be to
pawn false so that looks good for black
do I have to take on d4 well you your
only other movements Bishop f4 and then
d3 you're hanging on by the skin of your
teeth but no I don't I have to why don't
I Bishop F - oh yeah I thought D my bad
I thought d3 I thought the three one's a
piece no I mean I don't see one I forgot
about that night and such a you just
don't see a knight on c1 that often so I
just assumed it wins a piece for black I
was so confused down I'm like why can I
not just like Bishop f2 but I was
letting you talk thinking that I was
missing so you were the one missing so
clearly I'm but but still let me stand
by partially what I said Bishop a5 here
it's still annoying that creates the
threat of d3 yes Bishop a5 trying to get
d3 through and if I play 93 94 yeah
that's exactly what I meant I was just
testing to see if you could refute the
immediate e3 this little puzzle rush
warm up for you Robert I appreciate it I
love that you support me and all these
ways and you challenged me in with
questionable decisions the ambulating
tactical decisions that are making you
tan for you're gonna play d3 what if I
play g4 I know it's a risky move but um
g4 it's risky but you have to die but
then d3 g hop mmm Queen g5 check ok yeah
you can move your king I guess but DD
yeah I was gonna take any two of the
Queen's I'm of a pawn I know my King is
somewhat exposed but hey it's not my
game I'm just trying to salvage this
right Bishop d3 by Teddy that's a
sensible decision because well Knight
takes c3 Knight takes c3
first of all I think it's
he's not exploited box dubious opening
play in the best rate but I kind of like
that move okay 27 by Elena trying to
keep the tension right and you can't
take on d4 like Bishop f5 queen of fun
Bishop takes d4 because rook to d8 and
there's problems down the D line here
with the bishop pin to the Queen yeah
and that's an annoying little thing that
white constantly oh can I take a deer
can I take it here that sucks
a lot of time out of White's clock so
Teddy once again I mean it's it must be
so hard to just I mean this is the final
game of the five-minute portion he's
thinking about all of those
opportunities he has and now once again
alina has the initiative so very
practical decision by elena to play b5
if she wins this game i mean that's a 5
point lead and that would be very bad
news for Teddy Coleman because he has
been able to keep ahead in the Blitz
portions and then struggle through the
bullet but just make it through and I
think this is you know of course is as
big as deficit in any of the Majesty's
played thus far in lena cash lanskaya
with all due respect to Danni and Levy
alina is the strongest player of his
opponents thus far so being down in a
match against her that's not the place
anybody wants to be in a 4 plate so that
Teddy can try to play Bishop b5 yeah but
now is the time probably to take this
Bishop on actually undie 307 B 3 but
Knight 63 here feels right yeah and you
can take twice and take on a 4 I think
Teddy is kind of baiting olena into
doing that and that's probably going to
be a draw but I I don't think that's the
best black and do Alina can play more
ambitiously with something like rook F
to b8 potentially you know going for a
sort of Banco style initiative on the
Queen side not sure maybe she should
just you know settle for that four point
lead take on d3 and go rest but I would
strike while the iron is hot here yeah I
was actually saying about Knight takes T
3 Knight takes T 3 rook to b8 then just
to get the bishops off the board and
then put my Brooke on 88 so I have a
threat down the B file but rook to b8 is
also good right away because Bishop b5
is not possible for what some of you
want to play but Bishop e5 falls
rook takes b5 as your work on a1 at the
end of all this is hanging for free
yep good point and and she does it and
said he once again dipping a little bit
low on the clock this is a much easier
position if if this were to evolve into
a time scramble these physicians are so
much easier to play with black because
you know she's got a lot of pretty
simple natural improving moves why does
the one who's got to keep solving the
tactical problems maybe b3 but does not
inspire confidence either I was looking
at b3 is just the way to keep everything
together but I was worried about
inventions Queen come in d5 and hitting
b3 but for the moment at least b3 seems
to be a worthy move yeah I don't see any
other moves actually because you
certainly do not want to give up that
Palm Beach so that will be that will
just spell doom for white so I mean
maybe maybe teddies thing about taking
on at five first but but that all is
black to play t3 so I wouldn't do that
85 while he does give that pawn away
okay so it's his hope that he can just
distract blacks pieces keep her pieces
tied down gave him but now Bishop f5 I
guess is his idea Bishop f5 Queen if I
bend it she takes d4 oh because there
are no pins with roof d8 because you're
gonna be to is hanging first I think
right well first of all Bishop that way
Queen up five Bishop t4 I could still go
up t8 and if you take on b2 I snap your
Queen and the Good Knight takes up three
yeah
you're the worst I oh I thank you see I
take that as a compliment by now Robert
it's just painful to see for whites King
so Bishop if I played so I mean feels
like that's his intention at this point
to take on d4 but as you just wait
there's some rookie four moves though
like at what point so Queen F she takes
with the G Panos they have Queen f5
Bishop d4 there is like rook da trick a4
just protecting the bishop looks shaky
but but your defense I mean at least it
reinforces the bishop 92 I'm not sure
about gf though Robert that just seemed
a little too much and now 93 forces the
trade all of a sudden white is
or than back in business we might be
better here the black king is the one
that speak beginning is going to become
week came and say it but that's the
downside of giving yourself double
isolated pawns against Queen b5 managing
that's a nice move yeah it is it is just
stabilizing the situation and and at
this point oh I would release live yeah
daddy's still got to be careful that
second ring is its monka s I mean well I
can just take on a five and take on d4
and mm-hmm yeah and I guess well first
of all if you take on d4 and go Queen a
to Black's me a checkmate of Queen D
8.25 Andrew 58 I'll show that very
quickly check check and no matter which
spec Frank squared King goes to gets
checkmate I have the squares under
control and maybe SIG's very practical
sensible decision by Elena notice that
pawn structure even if you give away the
f5 fun having those pawns on f7 and h7
it's actually a good thing for black
because they're like spikes you know
that that stopped the vampire from
rising out of the grave it's a pretty
simple drop that was a very interesting
analogy you just gave but that makes
sense well the only reason I gave it is
sorry Ben no you go in there was a old
history I used to like the History
Channel and there was an old documentary
about about Dracula and the real Dracula
when they buried him I think they buried
him with spikes so that if the vampire
Rises out of the out of the grave then
he'll be impaled by those spikes anyways
well if you liked stories about Dracula
you should read the historian but find
out Elizabeth one of my favorite books
Wow look at us we're on the same page
here but anyways almost like we're both
history majors speaking of history
five-minute portion of this I am NOT GM
speed chess champion semi finals over so
when you come back there will be more
here on chess comm and we will have a
very special guest I hope so
stay tuned everybody we will return in
just a few minutes
[Music]
because championship so let's talk about
it yeah I've been following it closely I
watched all the matches I didn't watch
mine please help me you didn't watch
mine no I watched I watched your match
against heavy I was I thought that was
like the most spectacular match of them
so far really
oh wow okay we did go to overtime I
guess yeah it was I think the closest
and and there was like that one twisted
then right when everyone thought you
were dead and then the rukon was an e7
or c7 oh yeah that's right II hung his
rook oh man yeah well you did you really
did follow it well I got a of my game
next time now that I know you're
watching but you will be watching when
Bartholomew at you hottie Throwdown and
then your boy Teddy over there again
Selena your thoughts on what we're gonna
see in these final two matches real
quick um I think that John should be
should be a pretty big favor I actually
expected Carissa to beat Greg but it
didn't didn't quite happen and John I
expect to be a favorite but I'm hoping
for a close match
and yeah I'm yeah i support teddy I've
known him for I don't even know how long
I mean since we were kids we were
playing chess together so so I'm
supporting him to get to the final and
Bobby be honest are you watching because
you'd like to tournament oh you just
want meat you know to see me and then I
have to respond to your messages when
you hit me up without the tournament
yeah I'm just watching for you for your
commentary
well Bobby thanks so much for joining us
man and we're all looking forward to the
final four there and the I'm not a GM
SEC and now people know you'll be
watching but dude you had it you had a
great event
I definitely make a case for the MVP
overall and congratulations to team you
would say even though came up a little
short and we we hope to have you again
in events in the future yeah thank you
my pleasure thanks Bobby
well he loved the I am not a GM
speechless championship so much he had
to come on and join us for commentary
they won the only super Grand Master
Father Caruana is here with us Bobby you
watch
every single match thus far what does
Teddy need to do differently to fight
back in Sonoma
i I think he has to match his time
better I think that that was the main
thing all these games or at least most
of these games is that when he gets into
time trouble it's hard to keep up the
quality and that leads see sometimes two
really bad blenders sometimes to just
miss playing a position in small waist
and at least once to running out of time
yeah and you grew up playing chess with
Teddy Coleman so you know you've known
him a long time but it seems like his
time trouble issue has been a staple but
he was able to get past levy and before
that Danny you know despite these issues
but it's just that Alena is playing
superstar level chess right now and I
mean she's such a strong player I think
she's being more practical she's keeping
her time ahead he's he's often getting
good positions and I feel like he's been
getting the better of the opening in
most games but it really doesn't matter
how good if you're better winning the
whole game it really doesn't matter if
you know you it comes down to an
atrocious blunder when you're when
you're at five seconds or less so if I
if I was him I I would just try to keep
my time even if it lowers my quality of
play at the start of the game or in the
middle of the game at least I can avoid
bad blunders that would be my first what
the first thing I would do that makes
sense and well Grand Master Gary narrow
disky what do you think of course you
know the old you played is quite low in
the forms you know time management you
know against corpo he knows much better
but yeah but I mean with a three-minute
portion it's especially important for
Teddy to to follow his gut and I think
they're off and another triangle system
fabbi what do you think of aleena
repeating this this line what to make of
this position with that Bishop one on a
three I don't have the position Pro made
I need to I need to get it up to do a
blindfold yeah you just follow DJ wards
you know we're making you do this
because you're so strong Fabiana would
make him do all these analysis about
knowing the positions at all I I just
came ill prepared for me let me see this
and this I'm Alena has Castle queenside
here the Queen's I got traded on d2 so
different approach than we've seen where
Elena's been going for attacks here we
get a more you know position that's
gearing towards a potential complex
middlegame queenless middle game where
white still has the two bishops but it's
down upon right now but ship c5 being
threatened so b6
what about ninety-five here ah there's
ninety four okay so for the time being
is so holding it together right you can
always have 94 as a counter shot to
close it and there it is 95 but maybe
maybe g4 first would have been stronger
ah that was actually really sneaky with
you down yeah well gotta be at my best
and yeah so we see that in this position
95 Teddy say gonna think why is he not
just playing Knight to d4 and now he
plays it so Fabi
Knight to d4 played I mean like ease up
a pawn so correct us if we're wrong here
but isn't blacks position just good uh
yeah I'm this Bishop on 83 is also
horribly misplaced I the thing is also
if if she takes and then plays b3 which
seems natural
I mean he'll fortify the night with with
a 5 yep okay so she's playing whip
through which is kind of asking for a 95
but I it probably doesn't work too well
a 95 paid night and I see four was
was definitely an option that I think
they're considered yeah this is starting
to look like Teddy just going to say I
want to keep material level play Keaney
he's seven get out of the pin move my
knight over FC seven first and the point
is that blacks King is actually in no
real danger and this 85 c5 configuration
means that b4 is never possible for
white please fix there so it's scary a
fun yeah I was gonna say that rook T six
you can't really free yourself well now
maybe you can you can play Knight f6 and
get out of that yeah rookie six actually
is super annoying because of this point
on b6 and then after b6 Falls c5 is in
trouble as well I don't really like
Teddy's position anymore because okay
Knight of 6 you have to
I mean you might have rook d 695 this
this is seems to work out but still
after Bishop b2 the bishop was coming to
e5 and and it looks like black is not
fully coordinated right and again the
time situation Teddy's dipping pretty
low yeah this is the theme of the match
is 5 going to point out by the way Fabia
I don't know if you know this but as we
go forward get more openings you're only
allowed of sight I am games from that
opening so you can't feel like oh I
played this against mal it's not none of
that yeah none of that okay
so just think okay I know I know well
yeah I don't really know many games like
I don't have much of a memory for
players so I might remember positions
but I could never tell you the players
okay well then just let us know that
it's some I am that you may be doesn't
even exist they will believe you
this is this rook da move is kind of
strange to me because you're not ever
getting out of this pin like now after
rook d6 I don't see how you're you're
freeing yourself you play Bishop b7 but
you don't really have a next move to get
out
what about your Bishop d4 oh it doesn't
work anymore because it's just a rugby 7
ah yeah I knew confronted Jill of an f3
and I don't see your next move
so rook da really yeah I don't like that
move at all this isn't fun mm-hmm like
if I if it was my move and I was if it
was black moo here I would consider he
no rook at Phaedra something like that
just to run out the way just to free
myself somehow because how else are you
gonna get your pieces up and what do you
think
Amina's aversion to rook t6 has been has
she's just not really seen the move it
just isn't coming to mind or is there
some potential drawback that is making
her refrain from it yeah I think her
mine was going in a different direction
she wants to go for g5 but I don't like
this because it allows Bishop f3 stuff
and then that does help like potentially
solve the pin or Bishop c6 Oh Teddy
loves putting that Bishop from b7 c6
he's gonna could bail out with Bishop c6
Bishop f6
right this is maybe not just a bailout
because today the rook on c6 the end
game is still unpleasant for black but
it shouldn't I think she should do yeah
it's a good spot because the 97 is
actually just pinned still even after
all the stuff has happened but okay so
this is indeed Kirino Danya spotting
those tactics there yeah at first I
thought it's a drum but that rook on c6
is also pegged to c6 is that b6 bonus
you know is gonna come back to haunt
flag at some point can black try to make
use of the fact that his King is more
active with some kind of h5 q g5 King
edge for I know it's a long story but I
need some sort of activity otherwise I
can't move anything well I think h5
white will play King d2 and I don't see
a counter play really going anywhere
King g5 King III King g4 new I can play
f4 end and you're tied to the H pollen
anyway so I don't really I mean maybe
it's been annoying with the King on h3
but it's not very terrifying Kalka but I
mean we always talk about the threat
being stronger than the execution but
I'm with you then it doesn't actually
look that scary at some point black will
need to move this rook right you can't
just leave your rook on c6 so passively
or maybe you can and that's the way to
hold but something about this looks you
know if you know Brooke stays here I
think the idea is that you get your
condition when you play h4 white will
respond to that with Luke h7 to Tyler
came to age 4 and then you'll play rook
d6 and get calculated with t1 so it
probably becomes concrete if I could get
her King to e5 and time then black would
be completely paralyzed right and we
actually both players just about 20
seconds no teddies dip below that time
and king of for Brooke d6 here okay so
Rick see a time together through a fade
and that way if King g5 is reaching
actually it was a good move and check
what am oh now it's just winning for
Teddy what a move there me - yeah the
King g5 was a blunder I mean look up to
emerging - just picks up all the pawns
now yes overthinking it right now and
once again he's okay so the same works
but I mean it doesn't really I don't
know if you want to take on h2 because
your king will be shoulder than white
start picking off the bones Wow freaky -
yeah kingi five rupees to check Robo two
wins on the spot
oh my god yeah he he just wasn't seen
recruit you to it all this idea for some
reason still probably winning though
right I mean rupee 84 and aplomb just
rolls right quickly with whatever kicks
irrigation chute I'm working two seconds
oh my gosh GG 2 and E 3 Oh
rookie 3 King after you don't blunder
the Rocklin who's better than the odds
acted said eat it yeah Danya you keep
prophesizing things like this I can't
believe it oh I just connected my
headphones oh my gosh oh that's so sad
it is yeah can we just get Danya away
from this I was so flustered at my head
phones got disconnected Bobby you know
is somebody who you know please and it's
counted on much more than those
commentary when you see time scrams of
it is that like give different reactions
you feel differently now that you're
talking about it rather than you're
making the moves yourself um yeah I I
feel like from when you see from the
side everything seems much easier but
then when you're playing you somehow the
board just looks different right it's
always much harder when you're playing
so so that's why I try not to be too
critical players because when you're
down to two seconds somehow you just see
the board differently under the pressure
of time time trouble and everything else
then then if you're you know looking at
at the boards on the side
I completely agree and I always say that
it's oh so much easier to commentate
because I can sacrifice people's pieces
and then just take the moves back
because if they don't work I claim you
know we're all thinking of the ideas but
it's not making those ideas you know
work that's really essentially here so
Teddy's blunders is rook with one second
the clock it happens this whole match is
kind of been dictated by his time
trouble
more or less an ally no still playing
they're resourceful a because she could
have just lost that game any moment she
kept on going she kept Teddy and time
pressure and now that we look at this
game Danya and Fabi this position for
white we got the white side of a king's
indian blacks looks safe and sound for
now but whose attack is going to rage on
first yeah I think this is a complete
positional disaster for black I mean 95
was a good move and I would probably
play Bishop f8 with black just because
Bhishma theta at least allows you to
hold things together a bit I still think
like Queen before or something will
things will fall apart for black
eventually I mean if you played Bishop
takes b5 and you just end up with her a
really sad yeah we're teaching work c1
is also good but I I think clean before
some moment was was tempting I think
Queen before it just wasn't spotted by
Teddy because included for even maybe
well it only worked with the Queen on e7
because after night a6 we had Queen d6
on the b6 night hangs around with the
Queen on it on the 8th and 96 kind of
might pick up tonight on b5 anyway until
early in the pack now it's very strong
this is like tremendous and 9 a.m. is
then 95 and your blacks will take and
you take what the bishop is focusing
before and yeah this is just but wait to
give them that light squared Bishop it's
just I would just go for the a4 call it
should be father's I mean I don't think
96 working it's just 97 98 and there's a
check on that six-man right and now I
would just play Bishop takes like Queen
e7 or Queen da will be played and just
Bishop I for us it's simple you don't
really have to I am Bishop c5 might also
be very strong but before I think isn't
even easier way to do it I love it when
you just start you know making really
Bishop takes a form my mind is taking me
for some kind of your take on c5 or just
if something more dynamic you know yeah
gobble pawn convert this easily my worry
is that if things like you take on c5
maybe one day your pawns on the kingside
start hanging in man game with obstacle
or Bishop so I'd rather keep my dark
square Bishop for just for that reason
but Bishop c5 I'm sure is also good move
and and what he did is well he's he's
really going try to get the maximum out
of it keep the two bishops and take on
and I liked what you said there about
the h4 g5 type pawns where if you let
this Bishop escape from f8 in the long
run at some sort of endgame you know you
have to watch out for a bishop getting
behind those King side poncy Knight b6
by alina now just Knight takes e5 you
see in a bud and maybe Queen d6 I mean
barely holding things together but you
can't you can't take on a4 there yeah
you probably should play like Bishop e2
there and then turn your attention maybe
to the c5 pawn although it is quite or
platform is sometimes an idea to
play Bishop h3 and click the rook that's
that's quite wise in fact instead of
Knight 2 D 3 perhaps Bishop F 1 Bishop
h3 was an alternative there but it's you
know it's funny I'm so folks in the a4
pawn now because you mentioned it that I
kind of forgot that you could flip that
Bishop right around and take over the C
file that might be more important the
time event that he might be considering
Bishop c5 d c5 Queen I 5 and then after
Queen d6 you have Knight takes e5
potentially yep or he played nice cuts
no one yeah he divided that your idea of
course just to take with the bishop
there to get after the e5 pawn right
away made sense and now Queen 85 is 26
feels like seems basically forced and
now Bishop before is what I would play
most likely I was thinking Bishop c6 as
well but that probably doesn't work
after you just take on c6 the pawn and
take on d5 so it's probably still very
good but I don't know if it's the most
you can get out of it because black will
play c4 and then and then you don't get
a look-see for amount and light squares
playing it slowly 83 I mean I guess
there's no hurry
but again 30 seconds maybe only no
preparing up 6 uh-huh but the way I'm
having side yeah well yeah I mean but
desperate situations call for desperate
measures
so is Teddy trying to play Queen g3 and
at for just switch his attention to the
center of the board yeah I was gonna say
I think his idea is to play Queen out of
2 or Queen g3 anaphor
and that looks very strong I am
wondering about c4 here I mean just
because black has to do something it
really does leave it an item b6 hanging
so probably doesn't work after quitting
a 5 foot but I was curious for a second
button
but yeah c4 Queen I thought just picks
up the Queen side so no good yeah but uh
maybe doesn't even work c5 though as a
response I just like yeah some material
get some activity but Teddy goes Queen
f2 after the opponent f4 is loosing yeah
up for is just crushing I mean Bishop
pieces and then I would just play up
fire you you want the material f65
Bishop of Bishop takes e5 looks yeah
that's more stuff to calculate and he
does it that thought is more sadistic I
mean you can win that without even
calculating a variation so this is also
crunching yeah I mean nobody knew you
were such a bully you know you're such a
nice guy everyone hears your interviews
I'm really giving instructive points and
they know absenting a little I want to
just clamp down and give you no chance
nobody will think of you in the same way
over again oh yeah over the port I love
to be sadistic I mean that's a great
pleasure but yeah okay this was a great
game I mean he played excellently I
think and barring a massive blunder he's
just over peace so this so barring a
massive blunder which just happened
between even were there yeah that was a
massive blow in a moment you finished
that sentence it should dig but I dig
him but it didn't matter Queen I just
showed that really quickly that the
bishop my goodness and instead he gets
away with it but look at you two with
the commentator curses it didn't happen
so I guess another curse in this one but
yeah as long as he doesn't blunder
anything in as soon as he finished that
sentence blunders a bishop that wasn't
there about that was a classic Compton I
think Teddy realized he did that heaven
is his gesticulations so it's still a
four-point match I mean it was five for
a second there after Lina won the
opening game of three minute and I mean
Fabi you played in matches where are you
both in the head and behind me just how
do you kind of alter your mindset where
you get one victory so you should feel a
little bit more confident but then you
look at the match score and you realize
you're still down four points
do you play it game by game and just try
to seize the little chances here and
there or do you just go all in at a
certain point
um well I've had trouble keeping my
emotions kind of in check when I I
played a number of these online matches
I played one against level which was
let's say I have some PTSD after that
one yeah that was very one-sided I I
mean it just said things things went
kind of badly from the start and I I got
completely tilted I didn't I wasn't
playing chess anymore I was just playing
with my emotions and and the final score
was like a complete landslide for him
sometimes I managed to to keep my cool
but it is difficult I mean being behind
in a match losing number of games in a
row is is really emotionally emotionally
difficult to handle but it looks like
Teddy it's quite good at that at
forgetting about the previous games and
I think just something has to click for
him and things will might start to go
his way
yeah I'm with you for sure and I just
have to say Fabi I'm looking at the chat
right now and you're getting a son of
love including from fire 261 saying
Robert please let Fabi know that we love
him so you are loved like you're
appreciate them I mean you know
Valentine's Day I guess came early I
don't mean every day is Valentine's Day
when you're Bella times that came Kim
very lucky I figured I have yeah I'm
just I'm just thinking ahead here like a
true chess player is supposed to but we
did this game here Alina plays h3 we
have this sort of pawn structure it's
not quite hanging pawns to the slope on
b7 but c5 d5 situation at what point is
black have to fear d2 to d4 threatening
to give him an isolated pawn or is Alina
refraining from that for some reason I
don't think he has to fear at all um I
mean it's it's clear that black got a
got a good opening but I don't
understand why teddy is taking so much
time on the first nine moves when
everything went well friend I mean 95
now is kind
asking to be played but I do wonder
about some extreme ideas okay well first
of all Queen f6 is is very tempting
because you can't take on a c5 and that
opens up all sorts of Queen g6 Bishop h3
ideas so I would probably play Queen f6
here um yeah that takes in seem crazy
ten moves in and he's barely over a
minute but seaboard ninety four he's
gonna Bishop d7 he's gonna start
nah that's to have a queen up like
production like Queen G fought here I
think just automatically play Queen g5
well I guess that didn't happen and
Queen g5 now runs into f4 which would
fourth your queen on g5 you ninety five
so that's not good but you still have
Queen h6 there so you can't really take
on e5 so easily so it's not the end of
the world like we'd you far okay but you
know Teddy's not really type of guy
who's gonna yeah this isn't this the
time management's been a big struggle
for him and made part of its playing on
a workday because Teddy Coleman is not a
chess professional he works as a
software engineer for a start-up and I
know for a fact that you know he took
the his morning off into the afternoon
and he'll have to work after this so all
of his co-workers if you're watching
this I apologize if something goes wrong
with your company don't blame me don't
blame Teddy but you know maybe just you
know the weeks off didn't favor him but
we have to give a Lina credit right she
has been really solid throughout this
match he's gotten some positions we
haven't been a huge fan of but even in
those she seems to be playing more
quickly and more confidently and just
kind of out playing Teddy along the way
mmm-hmm just complete silence from you -
I love it thank you well no it was such
a wise statement that you know such a
wise statement shouldn't be followed by
any further commentary I think okay this
allows 95 I don't like his last move too
much I was gonna say I think that he at
some point he was gain out play but the
position started to look ok for him yet
but I thought
26 - or look at critical eyes Bishop
ephod - so maybe it's sort of a more
general question Bob in your experience
sort of when you when things aren't
going well is it the case that you're
sort of subconsciously avoiding
calculation it's not the first thing
that you kind of stop believing in when
when you're sort of losing game at your
game I think that sometimes if you stop
believing in your calculations or if
you're not confident in your
calculations that leads to a lot of
double-checking which is sometimes okay
in classical chest but in blitz it's
really a disaster and this might be
what's happening to Teddy explains why
he's you know done a minute on the clock
why he's getting to constant time
trouble if he's if he's constantly
double-checking his calculations yeah
he's missing tactics because after 95 he
sugars from Bishop takes e5 with Queen
g6 to follow so now it's just complete
turn on who runs no more not even a
sliver of attacking possibilities for
black yeah each six but I'm Queen denied
but it's not a knight it's not yeah like
Queen b6 98 what say you move your
Knights I know somewhere there's also
Bishop g4 to consider it should be seven
being prepared by Lina nice it should be
seven just might win or there's quibble
one idea is to watch out for
there was taken and king gauge 7b I know
then Bishop takes f6 how about there was
Queen B one things to your queen d1 yeah
but olena decides to play simpler
yeah because right now she can even just
take on c8 and she can't take on f6 but
you just played look at three right she
she doesn't technically have what hobby
she can take on lipsticks because Queen
c1 Bishan do you want still wins the
pita wins the pawn on d4 right that's
what I was thinking yeah and here this
is also very good mmm
yeah this is no fun for black you down
time you're down the position just Queen
65 Nike - so that was like on Queen dat
picks off the bishop oh yeah just yeah
this is hard to watch this is a
this is tough yeah it's becoming
one-sided
I mean it steadies just he's avoiding
all the complications and you know not
seizing the initiative although I like
this position you get the two bishops
you develop any complaints from you
Fabia about this opening oh no I think
that this was but am I allowed to say
non I am games is that yeah I think that
this was played between Vichy and and
Magnus I think yeah Magnus is white
against bishi and I think it was in
Norway chess and it was an Armageddon
game if I'm or maybe it just looked very
similar but but yeah Black has a fine
position I mean if I could keep the
bishop then Y would be better but you
can't really keep the Bishop g5 90 for
stuff like I she likes to the castle
which seems a bit questionable to me
maybe 95 and Bishop d3 is now is a bit
better boy yeah
and that way you know if g5 does
eventually come you wanted to put 94 so
that you can get the bishop pair off the
board but Bishop III played so yeah just
the two bishops right there's some open
space to work with there are no
weaknesses in White's position so I
think we like the start of this game
before it a slightly better that's been
the veining
how do you work this into you something
something that looks good Fabi into you
know making more pressure on your
opponent well I think the pressure is
now on black because White's moves are
simple I'll Castle I'll play you know be
45 potentially I mean I'll just start
advancing my pawns and okay castling
queenside really looks bizarre to me I
don't know why not Castle short I mean
you don't have to attack on the king
sadness I mean it might not be bad but
you don't it wasn't really called for
yeah I was actually about to ask you you
Castle queenside our King set but you
look at the match scored you're down by
five games I mean I think mixing it up a
little bit more does make sense although
at the same time that can create chances
for your opponent yeah but maybe he's
trying to overcompensate he realizes
he's missed the tactical opportunity so
now he's he's stepping on the gas I mean
this still looks
like nice rook t5 is very strong yeah
forces 97 and then you might even have
Queen g3 stone I was highlighting g4
you know when you were saying Brooke e5
I absolutely knew that he was gonna play
g4 maybe four but before then Brooke d5
still and I thought maybe 93 treta at
least yeah but that's still terrible I
mean you can even just take I would play
c6 if I were perfect as bishop a lot
Queenie it doesn't really I shouldn't
terrified like I think weird over up d8
there oh yeah that's that's a good point
baby yeah yeah that I would win a queen
and I and then you win the ephod man so
yeah I won't show it so I just win
support for nothing now not even 1970s
in that year yes 45 and it just it's a
blind spot for both players right now
yeah he's just he's just hell-bent on
attacking with his pawns well now
actually black is countering red this
pawn on f3 if you've ever played
efore then your bishop will see two
doesn't look very good so maybe you
throw in Bishop f5 and then play E for
then you're sucking a bishop it might be
a very good suck but it is a suck all
right mr. Scotty didn't we talk about
this not my pieces totally happy I don't
like what he's doing
it looks very passive now rook da black
it's gotta play on the d3 square with
either efore or some EE wrote something
on d3 yeah it seems like he's completely
inside of his own head right now so
Bishop f5 played Bishop f5 and figure
out the consequences later okay right
now man up black is probably probably
better because my D 3 is coming mr. C 7
can i play Bishop c7 to steal a long
he's totally gonna do that you know I'm
just trying to steal something for my
problems but also rug d7 maybe oh wow he
did hey Diane what was that no I wasn't
being sarcastic I'm never smoked yes I
actually Manny's gonna do it but 93 and
rook d7 does Devi's because ninety three
King bee will rook d7 the bishop moves I
can play ef3 and you can't take tonight
because of rook to e3 fish before yep
it's still too bad it's really bad I
know that how Bishop e6 here though
rabitor published a fire or peanut
butter well take on e5 next but I don't
know if some reason wouldn't digit but
Queens x85 is actually great I thought I
lost Queen C for though probably not a
good suggestion okay
you see what you just did it's not good
but you see what he did 94 I don't
understand because now white can take
and put the bishop on d4 it looks it
looks like it turns around in one move
with the issue with 984
I think she's hoping you will under the
bishop on b6 yeah well now it's hi
bishop deformed it's completely okay and
actually if you play f6 to protect you
7f 4 comes in and g5 to follow ins
whites attack that comes first
rook c8 maybe potential idea because you
can't go c5 that a to bun hangs is he
gonna take on g7 now mmm the endgame is
probably good for luck maybe g5 to HHH I
mean just go for some sort of mm-hmm
speculative tuck
yes yes Bobby you're real Teddy Pauling
was fair so the question is what do you
do after black takes and takes on h6 and
I thought we've got three and we're kept
6 but then I'm not sure works after
Bishop c6 rook f6 take on on f6 and take
on h1 I'm not sure that actually works
out for white
yeah it probably doesn't but it looks
fun so I hope we see it it you know it
looks like a mess okay three three maybe
she wants b5 but is that too slow looks
too slow yeah definitely cuz it doesn't
threaten anything because BC I'll just
take the bishop er right exactly so now
she or doesn't takes on c4 but not one
with threats and now just rook c4 but
Teddy must be completely Winnie no yes
wait he's rooks before that bad because
I want to go rogue c2 in the end and if
you take on c2 twice I've got Queen a2
Oh Lord we're about to see actually
unique Queen 8-3 I guess just my twin
Queen III keeping it in three years just
good deal it's necessary I think oh my
goodness oh no oh and was that miss by
Teddy because you don't allow that move
to happen to spend another three seconds
thinking about no I think he missed
Queen I three entirely and thought this
was necessary gotcha
and now I mean it stuck to that
perpetual so who's better here I think
practically speaking black just because
it's so easy to play black and so
difficult to play white with no time
yeah gta6 there that's I would be scared
to lose a rook here
yeah we're cup three is very brave so is
this oh my gosh see GG 3 kg 3 the king
save move but f6 is also helped feet
we're coming out aged 6 just go for this
hug I wouldn't forget oh my entire fall
fatty and we're not laughing at the
players we're laughing just because like
we're saying watch out
these things happen is this earlier in a
bullet situation where you have no time
to calculate you just overlooked that a
rook is hanging it's happened to all of
us many many times and it's just this
vid has been Elena's match from starting
that rains it pours yeah it has it has
definitely been pouring for for Teddy so
we have a exchange Slav that's turning
like a trump offski type of position and
how much times at 14 and a half minutes
approximately in this 3 minute portion
says down 6 and the problem is that one
minute doesn't really get better for his
chances because Elina just destroyed air
of rosin in the 1 minute section so
can't even rely on the hope of a
comeback in that time segment so I mean
what do you do here I know we say you
got to stop the bleeding yeah do this go
do that but the plot type of cloud foods
is over like it's just Alina's
somebody help me out I think you try to
get into bullet with minus four and I
hope for the randomness of one minute
going in your favor I mean yeah six
points behind is really a mountain to
climb but I think he needs to take his
chances in bullet I mean he's not gonna
make up too much of the gap and in the
three-minute segment anymore I would
just try to limit the damage made me try
to get plus one plus two in the
remaining games and hope that anything
could happen in bullet
yeah but with his time management thus
far it has not really been inspiring for
his bullet chances because he's always
down on the clock and to Lina's credit I
do think she's the strongest player in
the field but she's almost a grandmaster
she's got two norms her rating is just
about 2500 so she is the best player in
the field but you know this is online
format it's trickier when you play blitz
and bullet so you know things can still
happen but so far this match has been
just entirely enough yeah I mean you
know he's gonna win I mean this is
basically Muslim territory we've seen I
think we've seen like three four point
swings before over the course of speech
at Championships I mean there was an old
dude agree shook match I think oh I
referenced Reims again I think I'm gonna
get booted from the show now but that's
not entirely unprecedent but six points
is wait whoa whoa yeah this was a very
good move because if black had 97 he
completely consolidated now take Knight
f5 you kind of have to play Bishop a5
Bishop a5 and h6 but the problem is you
also lose the d5 pawn so white gets
three points and a rope for two pieces
that's no fun but he has to take on d5
otherwise you just resigned I mean move
first time later
I wouldn't think in this position
because what are you gonna do Queen c7
end and play a completely dead position
okay so is there any other move besides
knowing this makes five six
age six but night age six King g7 it
almost worked out but the night g4 and
there's there's nowhere for the Queen to
go and it was made on h7 besides that it
would I think it would actually work out
what if you're one for that light G for
them so that means you have one choice
and once you're selling Bishop eggs at
five and take aged six that's just such
a miserable position brilliant tactic by
alina that's incredible that was really
nice vision here age six forests well
queen g7 even or yeah i mean it's the
same in spirit though the good thing
about blacks position is that you can
move relatively quickly since why does
the one who arrested do something right
i mean you can't really do anything
block you can just make moves and force
white to at some point advance the palms
now rook c5 maybe it's sort of funny
that trying to figure out which diagonal
and your bishop belong done this bishop
on b8 it's a dark square all of whites
pawns aren't dark squares so your bishop
is completely useless bishop was great
on d6 I mean in allowing works he
I think Curtis chances right
because now the record serene f5 or in
the age five so my dad use the white
squares but I think you are right that
the onus of the position is on aleena
but you all know Queen d7 is just it's a
fourth ball about the onus shook of the
position I was gonna say with Bishop e8
he's going DJ back back boards but dude
you got I invented a better we have to
leave you really gotta go
I mean just gonna be me and Fabi from
now on it's far enjoy this beautiful a
beautiful Charlotte a happy to Fabi how
can you answer how I put up with his
terrible puns
I I don't I I think I think you're a
saint Robert I say to her st. s oh wow
Lina wins another that was a really nice
game by her and the bleeding continues
for Teddy Coleman as we're in the three
minute portion and just the blitz has
been all aleena thus far I just
yes getting to that point where it's
almost too little too late at this point
yeah regardless
seven-point game it's just crazy
Wow Bobby I don't called me a scene I
should go yay oh man you made my day
Fabi but in reality I just like kind of
shake my head I'm like wow I don't know
what to respond this but you know well
we even sanctified before Bobby and I
had the same routine Iowa man he won the
tournament so you know I feel like
that's there's already something good
going on and I'm a good influence on him
that's what I'll say that's definitely
true how do you think that the Iowa man
tea house is doing oh I hope they're
doing well I hope they're still in
business we're giving a little shout-out
to like pretty much unknown except to
some people in one city shop yeah I mean
you know mark was a great guy yeah
Marcus what made that place was it the
food or was at the things that happened
there not much happened there besides
the food yeah and the team yeah and
Bobby also continuously trying to use a
card didn't make sense so that was that
was a fun routine it's a great great
story wow this is di really wide and
think I'm gonna fly to the oil man right
now actually yeah yeah so this position
I honestly wasn't looking at the game
but now I am in whoa
okay so Bishop c4 does not win a piece
cuz Knight takes d4 Bishop e6 at the end
holding on there yeah I think that he
blundered the d5 pawn because Bishop
takes me five was I understand Bishop a6
black would get to d3 square but this is
just bad for white might be four and
ninety three is coming oh nothing you
can do about it because a3 still night
before silver so you have to castle the
night before Queen d1 and and just so
yeah I mean it's it's probably
completely dead lost for a while already
but but there's not much you can do
anymore
there's Bishop a3 but I have a feeling
that that that will probably lose to
something like Bishop d7 is this why you
know you're the number two chests are in
the world you see moves like Bishop III
when I would never have even
conceptualize that at this point I think
the only way to hold his position is to
be ready to play some really ugly boots
there's no other way to do it yeah
that's a swallow your pride here well
you know Bill Withers sang that right
please swallow your pride while a face
we all have a sorrow
so anyway go go back to the chest but we
have to build both best of Bill Withers
would I be I have no idea that is
actually whoa whoa
I know I knew that would be the reaction
but I also prioritize okay I'm I don't
ask the chat for much and if I could
never really talk to chat for anything
but chat
Danya doesn't know Bill Withers react
wheeze okay who is the you might as well
tell me who it is before a setting do
you know that song ain't no sunshine
yeah I do okay yeah I that doesn't I
know the song lean on that's a great
song my gosh I'm sorry
Major Lazer I think Bobby this is why we
have you know inside jokes and stories
and Donna's not invited right exactly
TFT I mean well I think that um Teddy
made the best of his position I think it
might have even even been better like to
movie for lists but he's not losing
he's not even down material he still has
a bad position buttocks I think the best
he could hope for after the opening any
is he gonna go some kind of never mind
sake eh to rook G 1 G 4 but then black
is honestly first the inside of G five
anymore
I would play b4 here I don't know if
it's a good move but see before allows
works and seven would some play
otherwise like c4 allows some squares
for the Knights you know well it looks
like white White's position is just
gonna wither and die that is way too
soon of a joke to make well I have to
now
be in the I know Whoville whether it's a
school club so Bill Withers just died oh
okay I didn't know that either so I'm
really on a roll today I think I need to
go back to I need actually gone to a
different school okay so even sings b3
Bishop c4 check at least keeps the game
going right well you can play Bishop c4
immediately as well it doesn't seem I
don't know if you should be too worried
about upon d3 because at least you're
not losing immediately after that right
Bishop e6 rook c4 and just blockade and
white squares try to hold on as long as
you can but with the time of situation
it's I mean at least you should keep
some time on your clock in a bad
position so you can find the swindle
when it arises but when you're when
you're down to no time at all you can't
even really swindle your opponent right
so window with night c7 is one of the
ideas just forking the Queen and that's
why the Queen went to b6 to avoid that
and have a g4 yeahbsolutely is any move
but do you really want to open your king
at a time like this
well when I'm down seven points in the
match g3 I feel like he's ya know I like
this because he's he's not ruining his
position and now after h6g fourth really
stronger because black could have played
g6 and some lines and now it feels like
the light squares and the kingside could
rip d1 I played queen g2 and try get g4
I mean anyway the Queen belongs on g2 so
right Queen g2 also introduced the
threat of rookie 4 which was um yeah I
don't know what the Queen's going ah
that's nice so never up c8 I guess
should be played oh you're tagging we've
maybe you don't even have to defend C
Phi yeah you do I thought there should
be two but there's Queen c4 well she
doesn't but it's not Brooke c-65 Queen
before I guess she wants but also
hanging yeah I know that doesn't make
any sense okay yeah yeah well hangs d2
so oh and then Brooke see after whoa
whoa
and that will be six Queen b6 min F - oh
no what am i doing this is a rogue
enough sex now maybe maybe queen c6 gosh
there's not one point four SEC we b6
should be made right and then we'll keep
looking each one rookie one oh you just
mean like that you're there's nothing
guarding that square correct oh my
goodness the time you know this was
worried he waiting for Alina she put a
nice game there but you know he had some
chances when Alina went come forward
instead of just keeping her position
safe and sound she went forward and tell
you down the time to calculate all these
complications I mean Fabien on what you
said earlier is proving to be absolutely
correct that yeah anyways sorry good
that's sort of what I meant because even
if you have a bad position usually in
blitz it does turn into a mess at some
point I think not just at any level even
at the table level an advantage is
rarely carried out to a win without any
hiccups along the way and but you need
you need to have the time when I when I
comes because it's usually only for like
a move or two that you get the chance
and you won't be able to seize his
chance if you only have 10 seconds or 5
seconds on the clock right and you know
Alina she even in time trouble she don't
she hasn't felt she's been too much time
trouble herself for the most part she's
always been above 10 seconds when
Teddy's down to the remaining seconds so
it just the clock has really dictated
the match and yeah I mean I mean she's
just not made virtually any blunders in
this match he doesn't beat herself at
any game at all which is obvious
statement but also very important
quality in these matches it seems I
asked for questions for you Fabi in the
chat and all of them are about your hair
and about you know when did you decide
ago for the young yasser look and well i
okay Bobby
who would you want a chest documentary
about
just who would I want it to be about but
besides you if you're gonna say you know
I wouldn't wanted to be about me for
sure yeah and I really wouldn't watch it
on anyone else so my answer is no no
longer okay I like that answer so
well-played and another question by diem
Captain Obvious
who is the best non champion chess
player of all time you're not a lot of
pictures that's a good question and the
best non world champion I think I would
probably go with with course oi okay
I mean he's played two World
Championship matches so I think that at
some point he was legitimately very very
close in strength to corporal and like
solidly number two in the world I was
also thinking maybe Karis but okay he
yeah I would say probably in my mind
question I would went out on that one I
can't really name modern players I mean
Levon is also someone who comes to mind
but since he might have a World
Championship shot in the future I don't
really think you didn't name players who
are still you know actively playing well
let me ask you something because he's at
Korchnoi being number two in the world
is there any some asterisk because bobby
fischer obviously was not playing but he
kind of gave up his World Championship
title like not saying it question of
course is a great answer he was
phenomenal but I always wonder how top
players perceived that era when Bobby
Fischer was sort of you know the
unstoppable force and then he stopped
himself by quitting chess so I'm just
curious you know if that changes the
conversation at all of course noise
still I mean so a great answer well I
think it would have tarnished carpals
legacy if he wasn't so dominant for you
know over a decade after that yeah and
the fact that he didn't you know
officially win he died and when his
first world championship title in a real
match I mean that would yeah you would
say his leg is he isn't as great but
then he did also dominate the chess
world for for over a decade so so I
don't think you can say that yeah and I
don't really see how you can include
Bobby Fischer in the picture when he
wasn't playing for for a very long time
I mean when he quit up in 1972 after
match I don't really see how it has any
any relevance in 78 or or 82 I think
that's a very fair conclusion to make
and I mean course noise was amazing
you had the honor of losing to him
relatively late in his caucus taking
that's Korea sorry to bring up bad
memories I mean there was a he played a
great game
mm-hmm I actually had the pleasure of
playing him on more than one occasion
the first time was in 2008 one time he
ran out of time it was a tournament
where the games had no increment and and
he was extremely angry his position was
good in the final position was close to
winning he ran out of time and he had
some words for me at the end but okay
that's I mean Victor was sort of known
for speaking his mind well there's that
famous video if I'm losing I think -
Safiya Pulgar and he gets flagged any he
has some words this is the first and the
last time in my life the first and very
clear since the very last time in your
life I used to think everybody knows
that video but apparently not I don't
think I've seen it actually me neither
it's you know you should you should
watch it yeah I mean not not obviously
not to laugh any question as a legend
but just to cement that idea that he was
a bit of a firebrand can we just take a
moment to recognize that you know this
random Viktor Korchnoi video about
knocking no but it was yeah when you
said can we take a moment I was I
thought you would say can we take a
moment some more in blacks position here
but yeah thank you and the corner of my
eye I was looking at this game but it's
becoming one of those matchups that's
incredibly lopsided and elitist proven
to be the stronger player and I said it
already throughout this match
to GM norms she is nearly 2500 rated I
always commend her performance of 2018
Isle of Man Tournament where she drew a
nice Gary and Vladimir Kramnik in the
first two rounds she beat Sam seven
later in the event she made a
grandmaster norm and she crushed that
tournament so you know she's an
incredible player and everything's going
her way right now in this game she's re
up one paw in the a for pawn is falling
but didn't you hear Bobby's thoughts on
all right I do have a trick though if
white plays rook takes a four here yeah
you take tiger cage after we would still
work out for white there but if you play
work C for the nineteen to Rupp C to R
okay four and the back rank checkmate oh
you're so devious I mean I'll just show
it because like okay she she also didn't
didn't go for it didn't fall for the
horse no I just wanted to show it
because you're saying it and the point
is rook a four button broke a 1 and the
king of me and we have this position
after f3 and snagging that second pawn
and F Cygnus now another bug goes up
three of them now but for once
oh she's now under 10 seconds but now
she is and that doesn't happen very
often so you know these kind of thing
you can make mistakes and positions like
this but my today is 1.2 second one
point of series okay it's just free
moving kingship she should play Bishop
rook c7 or something yeah oh there we go
take that another set of moves Supreme
oof okay I mean yeah to give credit for
keeping control when she's low on time
too because it's easy to even when
you're completely winning to lose
control of the position yep well yeah I
mean you're you're right that she didn't
give me any chances he was pre moving
she was keeping everything under control
playing loudly
Bobby I mean you know we're gonna let
you go I guess unless you for some
reason want to stay with us I don't know
why you'd want to do that but any final
thoughts just about like I'll stay for
the bullet I mean yes it's all of more
like
to have Fabiana car wanna go full force
in a bullet portion so we will return
after this short break in return we'll
get to the bullet and father in a car
Juana will still be with us
[Music]
and we returned here with some daily
question responses and the first one is
from Francisco Jose saying Paul Morphy
the way he conquered the chess world and
the way his cur ended is just
fascinating that's a pretty good answer
the second one here we have by alla a
with lots of numbers at the end that I'm
not going to read Judit Polgar with a
hint of the life of the Pulgar family
also fasting that has been pretty well
documented by many authors these nepeta
full documentary it would be great and
finally by si man chess Levon Aronian
any day big fan of Levon so some good
answers here Fabi and Dania I mean more
feet Judit Levon and you know father you
said Levon yourself but you also said
that he could still play for the World
Championship but in general what chess
players you want document about five a
year he said nobody I want to hear from
you anymore dunya hahaha yeah I mean
there's an interesting category I mean
there's this guy Gennady so Sanko who is
a grandmaster and an émigré of course
from the soviet union moved to Holland
in the 70s and he writes a lot of
memoirs about how Russian and Soviet
chess players were so I personally I
always find that the chess culture of
the Soviet Union and the 60s and 70s to
be fascinating and all those characters
like me feel tall was a fascinating
character and not only these people's
chests but also their their
personalities and the stories that come
from when these players traveled
internationally because a select few of
them were permitted to do so all of that
was fascinating but the story that we
have right now is the 25-minute bullet
section and they are off with another
Kings India they are indeed and now we
get into our best auctioneer impressions
here and night to be six once more
Bishop e7 trump-like c6 go for the
queenside initiative what do we think
here right now Elina well over her
starting time so she's comfortable in
this position are you so comfort with
his Fabi you like blacks position well I
think she's I mean still why does a good
position but she isn't really going for
c6 which I think helps white
but still why does a very good position
and black is not really doing anything
it might be fun to be called um maybe
with night t3 okay she's now she's just
waiting for white to prove something
here way incredibly fast still over a
minute
Oh Dixie 400 okay Robert I was looking
at next four sixes 97 and following
Fabiano's advice usually is the best
thing to do in this one case here I will
say the Danya some way to scoop up on so
good on you do I think I've secured my
place in the candidates no comment but
here be three prick let it was the a
file yeah that was a bit odd okay want
to play Knight c3 but he should have
done it the move before when the c4 poem
wasn't hanging right and night c7 now
just go okay the bishop painted at that
night around to d5 yeah play Knight c7
bring the Knight to d5 white still looks
good but it's outside H font here in
certain end games can be really annoying
as a decoy mm-hmm yes a7 look okay that
now he's never going yeah you pointed
this out earlier Fabi ho in an end game
that pot on g5 it's a strength in the
middle game but can become a serious
liability and it has and somehow blacks
night he's getting to d4 before whites
nah he's getting defy like 97 was there
for the taking in numerous moments and
here comes the Knights to d4 this one is
still holding it together so right is
there maybe Nightbeat no no III I see
you yeah but there's always a way to
defend the two pieces at the same time
okay so he has managed to finally get
that Knight to d5 and for black what's
going on here so it's obviously even
material still the pawn on d5 a nice
pawn chain here with the past pawn but
black has his outside passed pawn of her
own and I don't know something
how kind of winning rewrap my vision
from dy don't know how to do it in the
time situations crazy efficient soul
outside it is strange
I don't know why was he fixed arming
have you some rookie six maybe you were
just H 4 H 3 and Bank on
I mean of course that's bad oh Rudy six
now Andy searches very stronger than f4
f4 f5 or just even up Gordon why would
you maybe d7 but no now Bishop yeah bro
give me five broke 85 85 no Caesar will
find
pains me it pains me so many chances
left by the side of the road a huge
advantage sure yeah but don't take don't
take it okay you were so worried there I
was worried who's gonna take it this is
still winning just rook d4 and then pick
up the b7 pawn or force bucks played b6
and get a pass cheap one oh my bishop
IDO I mean he's going the most
circuitous possible route so my name is
king rookie six
there we go take-take-take yeah take em
b7 yep there we go oh my gosh just take
on g4 king D 5 etc and if king of three
key six Jack can you take oh so Teddy
gets a win in the first bullet game he's
going to be down eight points now and
with 21 minutes left I mean there's not
enough time for the comeback but it will
feel better if he can just score some
victories at this point but Alina just
such a dominant performance we're
getting this position again
Fabiano I think we have researched this
afterwards because this feels like it's
a lesson and I still am confused yeah I
don't really know the theory but clearly
what white is doing is not really the
way you're supposed to do it or at least
it doesn't though now maybe Black has
some tactical problems I would like
Queen c7 just to get out of oh gee for I
don't understand what's wrong with 97
example I don't know but I seemingly she
wants Queen g5 or some XIII I don't
really see the attack for white because
did not g6 covers everything
I think fully mm-hmm sure
and what you play at 4:00 at 5:00
tonight g6 I guess but yeah some kind of
Queen g5 happening here but see mister
how about b3 there should be I mean but
that creates a weakness okay and 994
it's you know play up six I would or
okay this is no easy seven no yeah
nitrous oh my goodness Oh missed 96th
range Nagi seven at all tonight have sex
Ted Queen age six F by G up and the G
file opens I mean oh man it's
devastating Bishop takes c6 was very
very I mean so really to take the poem
instead I mean even after bishops
decease maybe the best to do is 97 but
no be even here oh is it after Bishop c6
you have f6 after Queen ephod now now
you Rosanna
yep g6 Queen f6 g h5 is gonna rotate
every movie even jia jie anything there
yeah at this point it's it's all over
Wow yep just not as day and a
resignation has indeed occurred hmm well
I still feel like I need to study that
opening and this one here alright it's a
night of 6 e 4 that's what tape it
earlier
Bobby you must know something about this
right I have no idea I just I I did
remember in that game I think he played
like Bishop d3 Bishop g4 you took on e7
and d5 and there was Knight takes e4 I
think hey if I didn't miss anything
before F I only need four not
relevant to this game but I just wanted
to say them so this is Weiss
yeah why does the bishop before is a
humongous threat I mean this should be
for Ricky for
tweet 65 right now over GeForce hanging
for free but Queen d5 is also look wait
I thought this would be four wins a
piece here no no I'm saying instead of
rookie for Queen 6500 yeah that was good
uh-huh yeah here the Queen d2 block in
play 97 where we r c6 any network decent
moves maybe annoy way with Queen e7
and that also although I was just
thinking for a moment about castle
rookie - rogue everyone oh but it
probably doesn't work it's just it it's
just kind of funny black acid by rookie
one work you want to Queen move
somewhere right I'm not sure
White has enough they're rolling on yeah
not a believer but I'm also not believer
in the clock situation for white or them
is all really definitely neither am i
Brooke
okay can't go rookie - but just wait
this is kind of a clever f4 yeah a poor
monkey three king of two looks pretty
hahaha why one other port at full guru
crook g4 maybe is better for black there
okay wow I wasn't expecting that
repetition but yeah that was fun that
was fun indeed and rich rich game what
next nine point lead it's always you
know we feel for Teddy of course it's
it's hard to continue the match when
you're down down this map this much I
was gonna say down this match down this
much and and you know you're gonna lose
but you know he just wants to see if you
can score a couple of consolation goals
another interesting opening the
Cambridge strings ones for the last to
be five was sort of asking for Bishop of
six and d5 right and instead Bishop h4
happened which is a bit of a mystery now
black has a good position either cream
you know c7 Queen even Queen eight six
sort of comes to mind but it's a bit we
need for Trina core is pretty fun Wow
there's Queen eight for take that both
yeah I'm pretty sure that Teddy can hear
us like that explains a lot of moves
forth the good and the bad ones I would
consider ninety-four you know Dixie
Jason point but then Queen c3 and rookie
one fabbi your idea from the last game
on step except not done a piece hahahaha
true yeah Bishop e6 black it's all a
little bit worse for by - I know I that
was a great move I realize no no Megan
I'd see father will come into play like
Queen d2 here and then live see father's
very tempting
Oh God in Queen age six Bishop e5
teddies could be very careful so no
Queen easy one and queen h6 simply this
is like black is really tactically nice
do you like teddy is completely
unconcerned but after Queen a chase is
gonna start getting worried
yeah this is so scary for luck I'd only
just lot schism I mean well probably
practically speaking it is psychically I
think it is completely done EPS takes
Bishop g6 Wow be part of this like
should be completely winning okay she
wants to okay that's a good night if I
know like his back in it
what about ninety five trying to cut the
Queen off from afraid yes take you and
he's actually like a Triple P suck and
I'd yeah I'm Bishop e5 of g6 but then
work e7 and then maybe it's not the end
of the world mmm-hmm like if she yeah
mmm-hmm Wow f6 played now with the Quinn
turn f8 and okay so gaining a pawn but
now Bishop c6 limbs like stole okay this
wasn't a B yeah
don't say that was well handled tactical
portion the game but you know Wow okay
yeah yeah hard as comp dated it's hard
to to go as and pretty were same for
teddy it's the match is already over
there still o'clock but really the
hardest burden is on us the commentators
obviously it's all about the
commentators don't put yourself first on
you haha yeah ten point lead
I don't know what to say I think we have
John Bartholomew Gretchen hottie in the
chat they will be playing on Saturday
the Saturday they'll play their
semi-final and the winner of that match
will play Alina Cassius kaya for first
place
in this I am non-gm speeches champs it
brought to you by chess calm and well
let me ask you Fabi we know the results
of this match between Greg shaadi and
John Bartholomew who's the favorite and
why oh they're there they're reading
this too and now I feel kinda on the
spot on their round
I probably say that John is a favorite
but I don't I probably I don't think
that it will be I think will be very
close match in any case and and Gregg
won the last match pretty convincingly I
think against charissa I mean it was
close for that event he started to pull
away so so we shouldn't underestimate
him
okay what would a diplomatic answer love
it when you give me the most
controversial responses so I can react
accordingly but no I would say that
probably John would be the slight
favorite but Gregg has proved themselves
be quite mighty against Chris Egypt for
example and in the first round Thomas
tatarskiy what's going on here black
well at some point actually Elena
blundered the c-7 pond earlier in the
game and Teddy didn't take it raisin
black down upon her yeah oh well I guess
she's a 7.0 and then she blended the sea
pond as well but even one point isn't
one point is enough you know you know
one pointers or not still flag position
is well actually no can't you just take
yeah Teddy has an aversion to bonds in
this game he's no no no no no I had one
that's an oxy five rook c5 just take on
C funky I say comes a fine oh yeah this
is this is going nah going all on
pretending no Brooks III in 94 maybe
your 94 loose Queen d7 first I'm not
sure with 94 I can play Queen CA because
I have work c7 and then and then you
have 97 I come on exactly sure what's
going on you could take on d7 there no
but then the deep ocean yeah maybe like
maybe there's King f1 but yeah I mean
even Knight B 3 there how bad is that
I think whiting and one tries to survive
as well yeah although the King is so
close to that pawn that king of three
okay we're back
yeah now King e5 can see for come slope
maybe a four
bringing home do after is probably
superior to this because now I thought
helping yeah I'm not blunder than a far
Wow
yeah this isn't good this isn't good an
easy one and resigns
yeah so it'll devastation here again and
I'm in pain right now it's hard to watch
this honestly
yeah it's he's just mm-hmm I think that
once the match becomes pretty much
unwinnable I mean you probably Teddy
stopped really caring about the score
yeah five their g5 was in Rubio oh just
a moment
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah no I think probably have a point
though that when you already lost
imagine who cares if it's by a million
points or by a few and people who you
know maybe just we in this is the first
match there watching the Teddy has
beaten two strong players they get here
so it's not like you know he's come here
and just it has been one-sided match
that's for sure but he is in the
semi-finals for a reason he played very
well in the first two matches showed way
more consistency in those in terms of
the upside here he's consistently been
in time trouble he's been just kind of
floundering a bit and struggling under
the duress of said time trouble so kudos
to Alina couch and skya who in every
single matches played we've just been in
awe of her performances and this one is
no exception and there is a little bit
of stake based on the prize money
because yeah it's every point you score
determines part of the the prize you get
but I think you know all things
considered the players that care way
more about the overall match than a few
dollars here and there you know in terms
of when their their mindset and find
these games may I make one correction
correction Robert what's up it's like
when you say coach Lee and scare the
reference the emphasis is on the first
part that's Kelly and Scott not catch
since Kyle it was always been my dream
to correct you Robert well there you
have it
surprise surprise done and aired its key
knows more you're Russian than I do
you rub
my face weird flex but okay yeah
seriously you didn't know Bill Withers I
don't know how I've survived on this
earth so disappointing you
well I I knew that from the first day we
commentate it together I thought you
were making a joke that you put the
emphasis in the cash but you actually do
oh well I mean the things I say are so
wise that they contain within themselves
many meetings and jokes Bobby do you
regret joining us yet Wow I mean you say
yeah like there's there's a lot of time
yeah the whole matches ahead we're gonna
make night teeth you know John you can
make a mistake instead of insulting me
you can insult you and then you regret
it right here I mean he's been doing
great all game this one looks completely
winning fair doesn't really change much
in the slightest blow but for seconds
Ives again he's just saying so long in
these these decisions is dangerous now
it's like all of a sudden lights lights
much better of a sudden like two moves
later we'd just like to come on a six
you're very safe at least whites king is
the one in danger
Queen G - MJ played this is safe just
Tracy laughs you know he's just like
gone wrong is going wrong the one free
movie makes and I'm going back to the
game because that was brilliant by olena
and the reason why it's brilliant is
Teddy 2.7 seconds left so she plays
before hoping that he you know he's
going to fall for b5 checkmate and he
hasn't much time and he takes on e6 and
b5 is made so it was her last chance in
a bad position but that was a really
brilliant
Danya near disky type of Diaz yeah I was
gonna say she took that from my my book
of
bullet moves I mean that's I think Ali
reza firs introduced a density into the
public eye there the whole concept of
you know you you predict on your
opponent pre-move something and you do
something as dirty as possible in that
moment but before it's also just an
objective chance and these matches
you can't talk about someone being dirty
you have to go for the win in every game
and and and we've seen olena's
incredible gentleman this before when
she you know she's given draws and you
know she's one of the classiest players
out there i don't even know what to say
you know bobby you mentioned another
ease of perugia and obviously everybody
knows that raises prowess are there any
other kind of juniors out there that
maybe lesser-known that you see as like
the potential future of chess
no I'd try not to think about it too
much I mean I don't want to think about
my future retirement at the hands of
some 10 year old kids who we were gonna
be you know playing World Championship
magic something yeah why would I want to
think about that you know just some
players that you have fun competing
against for the next bunch of years you
know maybe Annie Hall sahrin or
Jeffrey's young or no that's true I I
mean it is also exciting to see the
let's say the next problem talk players
coming up and I think the players you
mentioned are already kind of
established like like Jeffrey is quite
an established player and I'm not at all
new name you know we we've been seeing
his progress for years not yeah and
Niehaus arms well and and of course I
mean Perugia is already legitimately
atop top chess player in the world who
competes with you know with the best of
the best but I I mean I also don't don't
really follow let's say the less
well-known junior players who were up
coming up in the world
right so Elina just just hung the rope
yeah she she must've met it was me yeah
and Teddy took a piece that was offered
to him yeah no I mean Fabio your point
of view makes sense because you're
focused on your career so if you start
putting too much attention on some of
these like younger players and yeah then
just changes your mindset but I do think
we have seen some really good towns rise
recently Alireza is the most prominent
of those but even some like your invent
for us to his it's even 20 yet he's he's
pretty young but he had such a strong
like Vikings a trend where you want you
won the types of semesters but Jordan
you know he drew you and that you've got
a bad opening and then you fought back
hatred Magnus from a superior position
he outscored his fellow Dutchman nice
giri there so players like that are it's
pretty exciting to see done thrive too
right ya know it's that's why i also
like for example what playing and I can
say because you have more of a mix of
players I mean still very very strong
players but some faces that you don't
normally see in top events and they
usually perform very well like I
remember when when honeyBun
scoring I think +1 and was winning
against Magnus with black playing this
game Navy and III I think it was
probably like 2017 7 yeah that sounds
right and he karaoke with black in a
French he'd be Kerrigan in the French
game and he like he was like
legitimately proving himself there and
among the top players and then you saw
like cruiser was was leading this year
so I can say event halfway through and
and Jordan yeah so so it is nice to see
well let me ask you a follow up then you
said you liked playing in Vikings a
because of the you know newer blood you
fresh opponents that you don't face all
the time are you kind of saying that you
wish that you could play kind of a
different cast of characters are you
happy simply playing Magnus
you know LaVon and Maxie make are all
these guys over and over again
well my happiness is more based on my
results and so I think your happiness is
based on my results but okay yeah of
course I mean like when when we were
playing Alabama I mean every every time
we both did well I was incredibly happy
I'm sure the last time you played a
tournament back in 2010 Robert following
closely but know me if you're
prioritizing yourself but I mean
seriously is it fun for you to play
different players or just playing the
best the best every single time is that
your main focus no it is it is fun to
play different players um and yeah I
think we're seeing more of that recently
too more of a mix of players in
different tournaments I think especially
now that that all torrents moved online
we're seeing even more but but before
that like I I played a number of new
players and for example I'll man I
played players who I hadn't played
before in classical chess and I can say
as well sorry I'm just sort of game like
transfixed by this game because so much
has happened yeah really
one I was listening to you but I was
watching the game like it's Bishop f3
coming like right now like oh is hanging
is that the last game no there's one
more
now there's one wire on last one for
instead yeah and then man made me man
you would say that's a great great time
too well I'm surprised Robert that you
mentioned brace yourself
you mentioned your didn't run Forrest
but you didn't mention his is superior
brother my Denman Forrest what you're
then of course and then my them no that
was terrible that was really really
awfully you were that's better than the
other pun I made it which is they I
don't you think that you're not seeing
the run forest for the trees
yeah but I thought you want to go with
when people do with pretty long names
together so like the Michael you're
invent Forrest Gump or something like
that but you said hunter like you just
threw me I'm so upset with you jeopardy
categories are you have to yeah like
Robert has Hudson and Hessian matrix and
matrix or something just go away I'm
done with you Bobby I'm so sorry you
know you may not regret joining us I
regret that you have been here for
danya's terribly have to sooner law solo
so bad Donnie with I am level puns in
the jet
well I'm even I am level that's FM did I
make an I am norm no that's funny I
played this disastrous us championship
mm I think 2016 did you lose the fabi I
thought I lost probably that you're
after that but I played okay in that one
but I got last place in my only
consolation is that I actually did make
an IM not lyng me out of 11 so got it
Bobby I don't know what else to ask you
right now because yeah I feel like we've
gone off the rails
it well then what's your next game just
like Teddy's position yes well when's
your next event um yeah I know it you
mean my next on line or well any sort of
left now the event organized by the San
Luis Chess Club which is starting I'm
not exactly sure when but I think they
just released a press announcement about
the event it's going to be two matches
between the top American players so I'll
be playing he car will be playing West
simply playing and Wendy or Dominguez
will be playing and it's going to be
rapid chess with some slight twists in
terms of the scoring system got it I'm
sorry dude she's subject again but
apparently Teddy's fiance came out with
the piece costume which I'm verbs I
didn't see because I was focusing on our
conversation but I've been waiting for
that moment so I hope I'm also fixed by
the game again by the way this is
fascinating I hope you returns yeah this
Kings on beat three now oh no but we did
see three and four maybe one point offer
draw professional clearly yeah like it
was I mean white had not a single threat
so what was broken three because he
could have played working one-on-one
resigns because there's no threats we
need three Teddy again taking the most
circuitous possible around here to win
this game yeah Queen c4 man he's gonna
he's gonna give up all this bonds at
this rate he's finding a way to luckily
takes ok well now at this point well
Teddy Teddy gets a win he ends on a
positive note unfortunately for him this
was all Elina creditor we will hear from
both players when return after this
short break
[Music]
and we returned with both players after
what was a tough matchup for you Teddy
we'll start with you and congratulations
to Alina but Teddy what do you think
went wrong in this match compared to
your early Matt earlier matches that
resulted in your favor yeah I mean a
couple things first of all I think Alina
was just way too good so congratulations
I felt like she kind of had all the
answers and even when I had good
positions she kind of dug her heels in
and defended really well and it was hard
for me to break through and then I also
think like on my side I think I was way
too cautious I think I played very
slowly and then I found myself in time
pressure every time and so I think I
needed to play with a little bit more
confidence yeah novena on your end I
mean it seemed like everything was going
your way but you also were constantly
pretty far ahead on the clock so was
that a conscious effort by you to stay
ahead on the clock and you work out
things in Teddy's time travel well it's
always a pleasure to have more time than
your opponent especially that I
understood that again I was getting
slightly out prepared and so I thought
that I will have some tricks if I have
more time so I said that that was my
only way to play so to put pressure on
on clock on the clock and then in time
travel to find maybe some tricks and I
think that there were some blunders from
Teddy's side just exactly because he was
in time trouble
well again Elena congratulations you
have a question for both of you I'll
start with you teddy do you feel it all
motivated after what was an excellent
performance in the speech at table deep
you're motivated to play more
tournaments and study more how do you
feel I mean of course there's no
tournaments right now but what is your
your feel like in terms of coming back
into the tournament play yeah for sure
yeah I actually because of this I've
like bought a couple books that I want
to read also have been you know to
prepare for this there are a couple of
players who I like to kind of prepare
with and we kind of talked about
continuing to do that afterwards so for
sure I think it's something where I want
to like keep keep getting back into
chess and and there are like a lot of
tournaments online now so maybe I'll
start playing in those too
alena question for you are you going to
be watching the match on Saturday and
between John Bartholomew and Greg
Shehadeh is there an opponent who whom
you would like to play or will you kind
of just be impartially taking notes and
preparing for both of them
okay maybe not a good answer but I'm not
going towards this match well I I just
heard that everyone is saying that
Bartolome is very strong so probably I
should be scared that he will win but I
honestly I've never played against any
of these players so it will be new for
me and to me honestly it doesn't matter
who win I will just see that and then
prepare afterwards but of course I will
tell you these games afterwards well you
said the word scared but Alina I've
never seen you be scared of anybody
including a nice giri and Vladimir
Kramnik so you just go in no matter who
your opponent is and just play the board
I know it everyone wants to do that
but how do you make sure that that
happens well I was scared
playing kramnik it was that I have to
thank my husband because well when I saw
the pairings I was so happy that I'm
going to play such from player that I
actually didn't care about the result I
just thought that my goal in this
tournament would be to play with as many
such strong players as possible and my
husband told me that you are wrong you
should just go there and try to beat
them so so then I understood that yeah
why why not I mean we're all people and
there are no no titles or ratings that
are making moves but just people right
so everyone could have better they all
were so well speaking of your husband
and people I mean he beat me on the way
to winning the 2018 Isle of Man so does
he thank me a little bit for his
tournament victory there you should ask
him but I think that he thinks everyone
should be there
I'm glad you know I just want to make
sure I was appreciated take Teddy back
to you who you were playing very quickly
in some of the openings and you're
repeating lines so you said you've been
studying you know would you switch it up
if you could play this match over again
would you change your openings at all or
do you feel like the openings were not
the problem yeah you know I I think one
of the opening lines I kept playing into
over and over again was um you know the
triangle and I think in retrospect I
think it was a bad choice for this these
fast time controls because even though I
walk away with a pawn or you know I get
an extra pawn I think white just has a
lot of pressure and the bar ferme my
accuracy is much higher than Helena's in
those positions and so I probably
wouldn't have played that again you know
also I played a couple times early on
against the Kings India in this line
with aged four I saw that canary who had
played this idea and so I tried try it
out but after the first two games didn't
go according to plan I switched to like
the more standard g4 idea so and I think
that went a lot better for me so there's
definitely some adjusting along the way
but yeah I definitely wish I might have
switched it up a little bit more yeah
that makes sense well Teddy we know you
need to get back to work so which is one
last question for you aleena do you have
any other online events coming up or are
you just gonna continue working on your
chest and then yeah your next event will
be the final of this tournament I think
that the next will be title Tuesday
probably it will be the next one then I
will play the final and a part of this
I'm just working on tres on the normal
basis like everyday you know training
sometimes playing with my husband but
not so much on my interest okay well
it's clearly paying off in aleena
congratulations once again Raja you have
so many fans here and Teddy you've also
earned yourself a ton of fans as well
sorry the mention go your way and I'm
sure what will speak later thanks guys
all right well thanks to both players
for what was a great match and as Alina
talked about well what's she gonna play
title Tuesday and it's for title players
and every single Tuesday yester yeah
title you want to play you can play the
likes of a car Nakamura Fabiano Maxine
Vasily Brown Alexandra Ksenia Nina is
playing in those dunya I know you
playing them as well so it's very fun
indeed but we now have a finalist in the
I'm no Jim speechless champion here you
see a Lena Constance guy's name there in
the fine print and right in the center
Danya John Bartholomew Greg jihadi who
is Alina gonna take on a final well I
see in the check Greg Shahada is
whipping up a storm he is I mean to say
that he is confident is to say nothing
and John has been laying low the last 30
45 minutes he'll try to let his moves do
the talking I think it's I think it's
gonna be a very close match I can't make
him do I have to make a prediction I
like both of them so much yeah but Greg
was trash-talking the Scandinavian but
he's he's gonna retire right and only
because of that I think that's that
crosses the border so that is why I'm
gonna have to go John but Man Man Man
Man Man Man hey guys it's John we're
gonna have to see it's gonna be a
fascinating match so you will not want
to miss it that is gonna be on Saturday
at 4 p.m. Pacific time and what do you
think about this match that we just saw
her up or not as close as maybe we
thought it would be but still
fascinating well Alina certainly proved
herself to be the better player today
that's for sure and and we've talked
about all along Alina is the strongest
classical chess player in this entire
field but she's showing that her skills
over the board translate online she's
working hard she talked about it and
working on chess with her husband every
single day it's clearly paying off and
for teddy we may have to say goodbye to
him for this tournament but you know he
has gained many new fans beating Danny
wrench beating Gotham chest leve Rosman
along the way some people who are you
know the faces of the chess world so
Teddy should be proud of himself
even though Ted can go his way and I
want to thank all of our viewers we
still have so many of you with us here
you make these shows possible you make
it you know so much fun for me and for
Dania we had Fabiano Caruana joining us
today but for now we must sign off I'm
sorry to bid you adieu and I want you
know just one more time thank you thank
you thank you for tuning in says I am
NOT GSP chess champ ship match brought
to you by chess calm
[Music]